So, moin Leute, ich weiß relativ früh, aber mir ist gestern Abend aufgefallen, da war es schon zu spät zum Streamsorn, dass doch tatsächlich Season 5 rausgekommen ist von Battlefield 2042.
Ich hab das überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Schirm, also ich wusste prinzipiell, dass das rauskommt, aber ich hatte keine Ahnung, dass das quasi schon, ja, gestern gewesen ist.
Letzte Runde Battlefield, genau.
Ne, es kommt angeblich noch mittags, ja, heute ist Feiertag, oder?
Also zumindest in Hessen ist Feiertag.
Naja, ähm, also, man muss immer sagen, in einer Sache hab ich schon mal falsch gelegen.
Das Scam, jawoll.
Genau.
Ähm, ja, also, in einer Sache hab ich schon mal wirklich falsch gelegen, und das muss ich auch tatsächlich mal jetzt zugeben an der Stelle.
Da hab ich, glaub ich, sogar im letzten Video schon gekeckelt.
Ähm, ne, also, es gibt ernsthaft Leute, ja, die sind 38, sitzen beim Rechner und benutzen Keckel in ihrem normalen Satzbau.
Also, in einer Sache hab ich wirklich falsch gelegen, und zwar, dass mit Season 4 Schluss ist.
Ich hab ja prophezeit, nach dem verkackten Start machen die das Mindeste, was sie machen müssen, und danach machen sie gar nichts mehr für das Game.
Gut, man muss sagen, so, ein bisschen, also, ganz Unrecht hatte ich nicht.
Das Game, weiß ich nicht, ob das mittlerweile, es hat halbwegs Release-Zustand vielleicht schon erreicht, ja, so, man könnte so langsam mal in die Beta gehen.
Ich mein, die Rotz-Maps sind immer noch nicht richtig überarbeitet, nicht alle zumindest.
Weiß gar nicht, wie es mit Hourglass aussieht, ist die Hourglass-Überarbeitung jetzt eigentlich mit dabei?
Wir müssen erst mal ein bisschen in die Patch-Notes gucken, bevor wir anfangen.
Ich hab vorhin schon mal aufgemacht und die ganzen Pop-Ups weggedrückt, weil das ist halt auch wieder geil, ne?
Du machst das Game zum ersten Mal auf, hast mal fünf Pop-Ups.
So, zeig mal her, Battlefield-Patch-Notes, äh, BF, äh, News, müssen wir mal gucken.
News und Updates, Briefing-Entwicklungsdritt, ne, Patch-Notes für Season 5.
Die gibt es, die gibt es, ich hab die letzten sogar gesehen.
Ja, Update 5, da ist es doch.
Stripes, moin, danke für den Massive Sub.
Wer sich wundert, warum die Emotes heute so leise sind, das liegt daran, weil ich die Gesamt-Lautstärke runterdrehen musste,
weil Battlefield irgendwie den Hang dazu hat, extrem laut zu sein mit meiner Default-Sound-Lautstärke und ich weiß nicht genau warum.
Das ist so eines der Merkwürdigkeiten, die dieses Game hat.
So, schauen wir mal.
Season 5, Battlefield 2042, deploys across all platforms.
Ja, gestern, äh, 12 Uhr UTC, zwei Stunden sind es, oder?
14 Uhr, ja, genau, zwei Stunden CEST.
Ich bin mir heute nicht sicher, wie lange ich es aushalte, mal gucken.
Es hängt drauf, es hängt vom Game ab, wie lange ich es heute aushalte.
Und der Titel ist Programm, ne, ich habe jetzt monatelang das Game nicht mehr angefasst.
Leider sieht man es hier nicht, weil ich habe es vorhin schon gestartet.
Ähm, leider sieht man nicht, wann ich zuletzt gespielt habe.
Aber ohne Scheiß, es ist Monate her.
Also, prepare for Pepega-Aim.
Ich meine, ich habe zwar den ein oder anderen Shooter gespielt in letzter Zeit, aber
ob ich in Battlefield noch was treffe, sei mal dahingestellt.
Mal gucken, wir werden wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Rush spielen, weil das der einzige Spielmodus ist, den ich in dem Spiel aushalte.
Okay, also was gibt's Neues? Neuer Content, zeigt mal.
Okay, das Bild konnte man natürlich auch nicht höher auflösend machen.
Neue Map reclaimed.
Es gibt Mini-Granaten, Anti-Tank-Granaten und eine Spring Grenade wahrscheinlich.
So was, was dann vom Boden hoch springt.
Neue Weapons, Keg W46.
Ist das die G36?
Ist das die G36, ohne dass sie die Namensrechte noch an der G36 haben?
Was ist das für ein Dateiname?
Wordpress wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, wie Wordpress Sachen resized.
StaticAsset1JPGAdaptCrop16zu9145withJPG
Just Wordpress Things. Ich vermute mal, dass das irgendwelche Wordpress Shit ist, ich weiß es aber nicht.
An's Trinken erinnern, Dankeschön, Dankeschön.
Ja, ihr habt recht, ihr müsst mich an's Trinken erinnern. Ich hab extra neue Teetassel hingestellt.
Also, nee, mit Tee drin, ja, sonst wär's ja irgendwie reichlich unsinnig.
Versuchen die das 2042 im Namen zu verstecken?
Ich glaube, das Logo sah schon immer so aus auf diesen Bildern.
Aber ja, man könnte, man könnte es vermuten.
Und wahrscheinlich wäre es nicht die schlechteste Idee, das zu verstecken im Namen, ja.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, also.
New Store Items. Wait a minute.
Die promoten für eine neue Season, dass es jetzt neue Microtransactions gibt.
Geil, okay, aber ich mein, der Shop ist halt auch lächerlich.
Da ist kaum was drin, geschweige denn was, was ich haben will.
Äh, New Experiences. Blablabla, blablabla.
Ja, das war ein Pop-Up, was ich vorhin weggeklickt hab.
Full Year of Content. Okay, okay.
Moment, die sagen ja auch Catch Up. Meint ihr, das ist absichtlich so geschrieben?
Catch Up on a full year of content.
Die schreiben nicht Catch Up on a year full of content.
Die schreiben full year, nicht year full of content.
Weil man muss sagen, das Jahr war nun wirklich nicht voller Content für das Spiel.
Erstens haben sie viel zu spät angefangen mit ihren Content Drops.
Und zweitens, so wirklich viel kam ja auch gar nicht.
Es kam wirklich nur das, und wie ich das quasi so gesagt hab,
mehr oder weniger, aber so das Mindeste, was sie versprochen haben,
plus das, was ich quasi auch in einem meiner allerersten Battlefield-Videos gesagt habe,
pack doch einfach den ganzen alten Mist noch mit rein,
dass die Waffenleiste wenigstens nicht so leer aussieht.
Und die sieht jetzt tatsächlich auch ein bisschen voller aus.
So, es gibt neue Skins und Gedöns.
Oh, Squad Management. Wait a minute, kann man etwa das Squad jetzt wechseln?
Was ist da los? Ernsthaft?
Legacy Feature. Kann man...
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe, dass man das Squad wechseln kann.
Man kann das... Ernsthaft? Man kann jetzt das Squad wechseln?
Alter, wer braucht eigentlich solche Legacy Features?
Class System is back. Gut, das war es ja eigentlich.
Vorher schon mehr oder weniger, oder nicht?
Oder war das das letzte Mal nur groß angekündigt?
Also ich meine, das Class Feature ist genauso wenig back.
Ja gut, ein bisschen. Eigentlich hat sich nicht wirklich viel geändert.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, haben sie sich einfach hingesetzt,
haben die Specialists genommen und haben eigentlich die Specialists
mehr oder weniger so gelassen. Nur, dass sie es etwas restriktiver gemacht haben,
wer jetzt was ausrüsten kann.
Und die ganzen Specialists waren ja eh schon grob immer einer Klasse zugeordnet.
Nur, dass es halt bisher keine Auswirkungen hatte.
Jetzt gibt es irgendwie eine Klassenperk.
Und wir gucken uns gleich die Patch Notes an.
Es gibt irgendwie eine Klassenperk und halt ein bisschen restriktiver,
was man picken kann.
Lass uns mal kurz die Patch Notes angucken.
Das ist bestimmt die G36.
Es ist auch immer total merkwürdig, immer wenn man die Sachen auf Englisch sagt.
Das ist ja 46. Und wir sagen 46.
Warum sagen wir das eigentlich verkehrt herum?
Aha! Ja, ähnlich sehr nice.
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Da bin ich gespannt drauf.
Das ist cool.
Bisher waren gerade die Battlefield 3 Weapons, die sie reingepatcht haben in das Game,
halt genau so, ohne dass du großartig was anlocken konntest
oder großartig was dran machen konntest.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Mehr, oder?
Okay.
Also es gibt eine neue Map, Reclaimed.
Das gucken wir uns dann gleich an.
Neue Weapons.
Eine Desert Eagle, oder sowas in der Richtung zumindest.
Keg W46.
Also ja, Leute, das ist eine G36, oder?
Das sieht original aus wie eine G36.
Die haben bestimmt einfach nur die Heckler & Koch Waffenrechte nicht mehr da dran.
Die Namensrechte, nicht Waffen, die Namensrechte an den Waffen.
So.
360 No Scope.
Granaten.
Ah, der Klassiker.
New Battle Pass.
Ja, gut, okay.
Vault Weapons Attached. Ja, das ist sehr nice.
Das gefällt mir gut.
Das gefällt mir gut. Das müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Ah, gut.
Skins jucken mich nicht.
Vehicle Loadouts.
Okay, fahre ich sehr wenig, dank der Fahrphysik in dem Spiel.
Bam.
420.
Squad Management Improved.
Und so langsam...
Squad Functionality wird Improved.
Man kann wirklich wieder Squads auswählen.
Endlich, Alter.
Okay, so langsam, aber sicher.
So langsam, aber sicher würde ich sagen,
wir nähern uns einem Spiel, was man Battlefield nennen kann,
wo man jetzt langsam mal dran denken könnte,
es vielleicht mal in so einen Public Play Test zu packen.
Oder vielleicht könnte man das Spiel Ende des Jahres releasen,
wenn der Play Test jetzt gut läuft.
Ich weiß, KQA, das Game ist schon eineinhalb Jahre draußen,
aber ich würde sagen, in diesem Zustand könnte man das jetzt langsam,
aber sicher mal ans Releasen denken.
Grade and Join, Easy Navigation.
Was?
Damage Unit?
Damage Point, was?
Ach, wie viel Damage ich an dem...
Hmm.
Ich bin grade am überlegen,
ob das jetzt was Gutes oder was Schlechtes ist.
Sollte man das einblenden oder nicht?
Was denkt ihr?
Also ich frag mich grade in dem Spiel,
was mir die Damage Nummern so großartig bringen,
weil die Time to Kill ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig hoch,
und man sieht ja auch, wenn er umkippt.
Aber vielleicht macht das manchmal doch Sinn?
Mal gucken.
Was?
Okay, das ist eine Sache, die finde ich bescheuert.
Also nicht die Änderung,
nicht die Änderung an sich,
dass man Accuracy und Spray und sowas ein bisschen anpasst,
aber warum um alles in der Welt nur Assault Rifles?
Warum, in Anführungsstrichen,
nerft man einfach eine komplette Waffenkategorie
und lässt den Rest so?
Gut, die Frage ist, ist das überhaupt eine Nerf?
Es sei denn, es sei denn,
die killen jetzt halt schneller,
wenn man sich ein bisschen kontrolliert mit Burst Fire und...
Ich mein, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so übel.
Das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich finde sowas fragwürdig,
wenn man sowas nur komplett auf eine Waffenkategorie drauf klatscht.
Naja, okay, schauen wir mal.
New Unlock...
Requirement...
Ist mir egal.
Spiel ich eh nicht.
Kamera Sprint Movement.
Okay, auf geht's.
Auf geht's.
Let's go.
Ach ja, Chat.
Das FPS Overlay in Battlefield war kacke, oder?
In Battlefield 2042.
Wisst ihr was? Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Game Bar, oder wie das Ding hieß.
Ich hab das...
Legit, ernsthaft.
What the fuck, Alter?
Ist...
Was sehe ich hier?
Ach, ihr seht das nicht?
Ihr seht das nicht?
Obwohl ich den kompletten Bildschirm capture.
Das ist...
Interesting.
Das ist interessant.
Okay, das...
Aha.
Das ist interessant.
Ich hab gedacht, Display Capture ist Display Capture.
Interessant.
Na gut, ich mein, dann müssen wir den In-Game hier play.
Dann müssen wir In-Game
das Performance Overlay.
Oder...
Wir installieren schnell Afterburner.
Weil ich will wissen, wie gut die Performance ist.
Weil ich mein, mein neuer Rechner sollte das Game ja easy as fuck handeln.
Das sollte eigentlich permanent
mit, keine Ahnung, 300 FPS
flutschen und flitzen.
Oh ne, nicht wieder der Scheiß.
Nicht wieder der Scheiß.
Wie das letzte Mal.
Ich raste aus, Alter.
Nicht wieder der Kram,
dass ich's nicht starten kann richtig.
Oh ne, ne, ich glaube es startet.
Oder?
Ja.
Oh, haben wir aber noch mal Glück gehabt.
Da haben wir aber noch mal Glück gehabt.
Sollte es nicht...
Sollte es nicht jetzt eigentlich
ein Sound geben?
Oder ist das...
Sound? Pause Champ?
Ähm...
Ich starte mal kurz in den...
Game. Wir müssen mal die Sound-Lautstärke
checken. Ich glaube, hat das Game
komische Dinge rumgestellt, hier Display.
Äh, ne.
Das sieht eigentlich okay aus.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht muss ich die Lautstärke doch wieder hochstellen.
Das
Battlefield-Sound-Settings resetten
sich bei mir auch öfters mal.
Aber immer noch besser,
wie Modern Warfare 2019,
was immer den Sound auf Anschlag
gedingst hat am Anfang,
immer auf Anschlag gestellt hat.
Auf... Okay, es ist doch ein bisschen sehr leiser.
Ich... Ja, es ist ein bisschen sehr leiser.
Windows bestimmt neue Soundquelle dafür.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Okay, ähm...
Wartet mal.
Ja, es ist natürlich wichtig, dass wenn man Solo spielt,
dass man 20 Sekunden warten muss, bis das Ganze
losgeht. Ich frage mich eigentlich,
wie wir das früher in älteren Spielen gepackt haben,
von einem Game ins andere
direkt zu skippen, immer. Ohne
zwei Minuten Pause dazwischen. Da müssen wir einen
Hallen-März-Infarkt bekommen haben. So, lass mal
Lautstärke testen.
Viel zu leise, lol, viel zu leise.
Das kann man hier drauf machen, ne?
Okay, ne, das ist natürlich nix.
Schon besser, bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob's
gut ist. Bisschen lauter
können wir, glaube ich, noch machen.
So, ja.
Ich glaube, so ist ganz gut.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz brauchbar, oder?
So? Lass mal, lass mal
kurz... Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich glaube, das ist gut.
Das ist gut. Excellent, excellent.
So, wie ist das?
Draw? Ne, Perf
Overlay Draw FPS
Genau.
Ich erinnere mich wieder, die Anzeige von
FPS war in dem Spiel so unglaublich
beschissen, da habe ich immer nicht gecheckt, was es sein soll.
Gibt es
Perf Overlay Draw
FPS Method
Okay, da mache ich wirklich einen Unterschied.
Ich hätte gerne ordentliche
FPS-Anzeige.
Ähm, und ich hätte auch
gerne eine FPS-Anzeige, die ihr seht.
Ähm...
Wow, die zieht aber ganz schön
hoch. Ja, ja, ihr seht das,
aber die Anzeige ist halt unsinnig.
Weil, ich meine, was soll das
überhaupt bedeuten, die Anzeige da oben?
Äh, 400, äh, 410
durch 2,6. Soll ich jetzt
Quickmaps im Kopf machen, oder wie?
Was das, was, wie viel FPS ich hab?
Nee, nee, es sind nicht 350.
Es sind 300, 350
durch 2,6
oder sowas. Also irgendwie 160 oder
sowas. Ja, wir installieren
schnell Afterburner. Ach, wurscht.
Komm. Solange
es nicht ruckelt, solange es nicht ruckelt, soll mir das
recht sein. Easy. Ach, das erste
ist FPS und das zweite
ist die Dauer pro Frame, oder wie
die es rendern braucht.
Ah, das ist okay.
Ich hatte nur im Hinterkopf, dass es total beschissen ist, die Anzeige.
So, wir müssen jetzt erst mal zum Einspielen,
weil, wie gesagt, prepaert euch für hartes
PP-Geheim. Wir müssen jetzt erst mal
zum Einspielen und, äh, wenn wir Glück haben,
kommt jetzt gleich die neue Map.
Zeig mal hier, was gibt's im Battle Pass?
Es
gibt ein Skin.
Nein, das wollen wir nicht.
So, ähm, so, was haben wir denn
hier? Äh.
Hä? Ist das nicht
das Gleiche? Ach, dieses Ding!
Who cares, man?
Wisst ihr, ich, das ist so ein Ding,
das verstehe ich in vielen modernen Games
nicht, dieses, dieses, diese Sache mit
Charms, ähm,
Handschuhe, Sprays,
Aufdrucke, es gibt so
ganz viel Kleinscheiß, den siehst
du beim Spielen gar nicht richtig.
Keine Ahnung, warum es das überhaupt gibt.
Na doch, ich weiß, warum es das gibt. Okay.
Seriously, ich weiß, warum es das gibt,
dass man in Battle Pass die
Tiers gefüllt bekommt, weil ich meine,
wir wollen die ernsthaft 100 Level
mit nicht vorhandenem Inhalt irgendwie füllen.
Das ist nur Sinn,
das ist, dass du quasi sagen kannst,
wir haben 100 Battle Pass Level, aber
in Wirklichkeit sind es halt nur
7, 8 gescheite Sachen.
Warum kosten bei CS-Skins 100
Euro? Äh, weil die Leute halt gerne
CS-Skins handeln und dafür das Geld
ausgeben.
CS-Skins sind halt so ein Ding,
da geht's
ja auch nicht um den Ingame Store
oder so, wo das kostet,
sondern halt, was die Leute bereit sind dafür,
über irgendwelche Trading-Seiten auszugeben.
Klar, letztendlich hängt's auch ein bisschen
mit dem Ingame Store zusammen,
also was Schlüsselkosten,
falls das noch dieses Schlüsselsystem überhaupt
ist. Ich glaub, ich hab die Map ewig
nicht mal, what the hell,
auf Attacker gespielt.
Alter.
Woah, woah, woah.
PPGA, ich hab's euch gesagt, Leute.
Ist nicht so, ich hab's
euch prediktet.
Es wird PPGA-Aimed as fuck.
Oh, Mist.
Ich dachte...
Ich hab grad noch nachgeladen.
Das wird was, ich sag's euch.
Das wird... Oh, Mist, ich hätt' bei dem anderen
rein-spawnen sollen. Woah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Wo seid ihr,
ihr kleinen PPGAs?
Alter, what the...
Keg W-46,
die brauch ich.
Vielleicht hab ich Glück, guck mal, da kommt ein Medic.
Kommt ein Medic.
Pogu. Pogu-Medic.
Aufs Dach.
Also wie gesagt, Leute, ich hab'n Monat...
Woah, woah, woah. Ich hab'n Monat nicht gespielt.
Der ist bestimmt noch da.
Oh, fuck, ich dachte,
das Messer trifft.
Was? Disarmed?
Anzeige ist raus, warum disarmen die das?
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, nein.
Von der Seite weggerotzt.
Ein Monat ist zu viel.
Äh, ich weiß leider grad nicht,
Chat, geh auf, was sich das bezieht.
Mein Boomer-Brain kann nicht so viel gleichzeitig
zu prozessen. Ihr müsst da nachsichtig sein.
Okay,
die Assault Rifles schießen sich jetzt wirklich schwieriger.
Muss man,
muss man sagen.
Das ist tatsächlich schwieriger zu schießen jetzt.
Du musst so tappen.
Guck, wenn du tappst, ist okay.
Okay, okay.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde.
Weil die anderen Waffen halt bis jetzt
nicht genervt sind. Es ist nur die
Assault Rifles, ja. Das ist es halt.
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum er nur die
Assault Rifles gemacht hat.
Und guck mal, wir haben jetzt einen Smoke-Launcher.
Pass mal auf.
Den rette ich jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, mach ich nicht.
Ist der Behinderte doppelt
Sprint raus?
Äh, du meinst
das da?
Nee, das ist immer noch da.
Okay.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie die Map überhaupt aufgebaut ist.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin. Konnte man...
Nice, easy
Snipe. Konnte man da nicht
hinten irgendwie sich durch, durch, durch
stelzen, so? Doch, ne?
Man konnte...
Oder wir gehen oben drauf.
Da bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher.
Nein.
So? Aber da oben sind ja meistens
keine Gegner. Aber man konnte,
man konnte doch hier hinten glaube ich recht gut.
Wie ist das Schiff hier eigentlich hingekommen?
Gibt's da schon
Theorien zu?
Hat sich ja irgendwie mal einer die
Battlefield-Lore angeguckt.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Lege Hänne.
Brrrrrr
Oh, von hinten kommt gleich was.
Achtung. Wie?
Kommt da nix? Was ist das?
Wie? Da kommt nix?
Oh, jetzt aber.
Oh Gott, Alter.
Keckel.
Aber meine
Legehenne war erfolgreich.
Ja, natürlich müssen wir das.
Ich hab monatelang nicht gespielt.
Kann man da drauf?
Ah.
Haben die noch ein bisschen mehr Container
hingestellt?
Okay, das über Range kannst du klicken.
Oh.
Geht das nicht auf?
Jetzt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher von wo.
Und unsicher, wo hier was geht.
Aha, nice.
Taucht man eigentlich
auf der Map auf, wenn man nicht
mit Silencer schießt?
Oder ist das irgendwie besonders in dem Game?
Ich kann mich da nicht mal dran erinnern.
Chatge.
Ach, fuck, hier geht's ja gar nicht weiter.
Ich bin übelst planlos.
Ich weiß nicht, wo's lang geht.
So, okay. Stell's nochmal hier lang.
Ja klar, das überlebt er.
Stop.
Shit.
Rekt.
Kann man da hoch?
Nope.
Ey, ich kenn nichts mehr.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, wo hier...
Ich weiß auf der Map waren hier an der Stelle
richtig gute Tricks,
wie man sich rein
mit dem Grappling-Hook,
wo man eine gute Position sich suchen konnte.
Muss man aufpassen.
Kommen die nicht eigentlich von hinten?
Moment, war das ein Wurfmesser?
Nee, neue Map hab ich nicht.
Man muss wirklich
tappen. Man muss richtig krass
tappen, dass das funktioniert, Leute.
So, jetzt gehen wir hinten rum.
Wir gehen hinten rum.
Gachi-Buzz-Style.
In der Hoffnung
guckt keiner.
Nee, nee, Moment, Moment. Kann man da hoch?
Ich hab was gehört.
Wusste ich doch, dass ich was gehört hab. Lul.
Okay, das ist ein Game,
in dem man anscheinend mittlerweile halbwegs gescheit was hören kann.
Beziehungsweise orten kann.
Von wo? Von wo? Von wo?
Naja, das war nicht auf mich.
So, geht dieses bunnygehopper eigentlich noch?
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich 64?
Spieler?
Oder ist das 164?
Rush war schon immer 64.
Okay, man muss richtig krass tappen,
damit man über Range was trifft.
Ich hab ein Granatwerfer-Dude
gehört.
Okay, mit Tappen geht es.
Mit Tappen geht es, tatsächlich.
Boah, noch mal Glück gehabt.
Ich versteck mich mal
hier hinten.
Oh, ich hab keinen Schuss mehr. Mist, das brauch ich hier.
Gib her. Muni, Muni, Muni, Muni.
Nee, nee, auf die Range.
Sack das, sack das.
Kannste aber vollknicken.
Oh Gott, hab ich den PP geaimt. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Aber immerhin 24, ey.
All that fuck, aber geht trotzdem
noch was rein.
Spawnen, please.
Bam.
Erste Runde, easy win.
Pass auf, das Game sagt mir jetzt
in der...
Die planten ja so total unsinnige
Statistiken ein am Ende der Runde.
Du hast 20 Kills gemacht
und dann planten sie
ein Revive oder sowas.
Okay, für mich für nix eingeplantet.
Was, was, was krieg ich für ein
Damage Dealt? Okay.
Die wollen nicht Kills. Nein, nein.
15 Kills sind selbstverständlich besser als
20 Damage Dealt.
Okay, na dann.
Wieder am Noob-Session.
Frage ist,
aktuell eher, wer hier der Noob ist.
Boah, Leute,
ich muss hier kurz mal rüber die Fernbedienung für die Klimaanlage
holen. Hier ist übertrieben heiß.
Leute,
hier ist gerade
knapp 28 Grad
drinne.
Mein Rechner ist aber auch hier.
Der ist grad voll am eskalieren.
Also,
der Rechner ist wirklich ne Heizung.
Wenn ich die Hand dort drüber
halte grade. Also, der
Radiator von der Wasserkühlung,
da wo die Lüfter bei der
Wasserkühlung quasi durchpusten.
Also, das hier kommt wirklich
wie ein Heizlüfter im Bad grade, was da rauskommt.
Ja.
RTX 4090 Heizung.
Also, die CPU
haut halt richtig rein und
die Grafikkarte vor allem.
Aber die Grafikkarte ist gar nicht
so, die Grafikkarte geht ja nicht über die Wasserkühlung.
Aber gut, die Lüfter ziehen halt auch
Sachen von der Grafikkarte raus.
Das ist halt so ne Mischung, CPU und Grafikkarte.
Also, es kommt richtig warme Luft hinten
raus und halt oben.
Oben ist halt der 140 Millimeter
Radiator mit so
drei Lüftern drinnen.
Also,
Wasserkühlung für die CPU.
Und die Grafikkarte selbst hat ja auch drei fette
Kühler drauf.
Rusch!
Warum braucht Rusch
40 Sekunden zum Suchen?
Okay, wir schauen uns mal was anderes an.
Haben wir was unlockt?
Battle Pass.
Wann unlockt
man denn eigentlich die Keg W46?
Wann gibt's denn die?
Hier, Keg W46.
Die gibt es
Battle Pass 28.
Hm.
Da brauche ich
aber ne ganze Weile für.
Habe ich nicht noch XP-Boosts und sowas?
Doch, habe ich.
Leute, Rush!
Neue Map! Bam!
Alle spielen die neue
Karte-Only-Playlist, aber die gibt's nicht für Rush, oder?
Die gibt's nur für Breakthrough und Conquest.
Oder?
Ich glaube schon.
Meinst du, ich soll den Battle Pass
Pay to Win auf Level 28?
Nee.
Das können sie vergessen.
Ich pay to win in dem Game.
Was heißt Pay to win?
Nicht so wirklich, zumindest.
Ich pay in dem Game gar nix.
Ich hab dem Spiel so krasse
Vorschusslorbeeren gegeben.
Ja, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich hab sogar Promotion, okay, paid Promotion,
aber ich hab sogar Promotion gemacht
auf YouTube für das Game.
Die waren übrigens
nicht so happy mit meiner Promotion.
Sie haben es zwar nie so direkt gesagt,
aber ich glaube, die fanden es nicht gut,
dass ich
zwei Promotion-Videos hochgeladen hab
und dann ein Video, ich weiß nicht mehr,
wie es hieß,
Battlefield 2042
Schande für alle Fans oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das Video genannt hab.
Das hat ihnen zumindest nicht gefallen, dass ich
zwischen den ersten
zwei und dem dritten Promotion-Video
ein Video hochgeladen hab, wo ich halt
einfach mal gesagt hab, dass ich das Game
in einem nicht releasewürdigen
Kackzustand finde und auch viele Sachen
bescheuert gemacht sind.
Und das
mochten die, glaube ich, nicht so.
Seitdem hat man übrigens
auch mich nichts
mehr angefragt, eingeladen oder sonst was.
Also, ich bin deadgift
für Battlefield. Aber das ist auch okay.
Stört mich nicht.
Mir ist es eh lieber. Wo ist denn hier was?
Oh, die Assault Rifles
auf Range, krasser Scheiß.
Boah, das ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne jetzt.
Das ist echt nicht so ohne jetzt damit
zu treffen.
Es liegt erstens an prepare for PPGaim,
aber es liegt auch,
dass das Handling der Dinger wirklich schwerer
geworden ist. Das muss man
sagen. Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, der erste Schuss
allein schon. Seht ihr, wie der kickt?
Die ersten zwei Schüsse.
Das ist echt
gar nicht so, gar nicht so einfach jetzt.
Erinnert mich an eine
Battlefield 1 Karte.
Wo geht hier was überhaupt gerade?
Fuck it, ey.
Das ist echt nicht easy, da zu treffen.
Okay,
PPGaim in den Busch und
einen gekillt, nice.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich wusste nicht, dass mich da einer direkt hitten wird,
wenn ich da oben drauf stehen bleibe.
Leute, die Base
da vorne,
die hat,
die hat ein bisschen, wirklich ein bisschen was von Savot.
Savot.
Okay, komm Brutz.
Au. Okay, neue Map.
Ist für alle neu.
Ist die ersten Runden immer übelst
chaotisch, weil keiner weiß, was er macht.
Oh, nice, nicer spawn, nicer spawn.
Dach, Dach, Dach.
Nice, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Dach stellst, beste.
Rooftop stellst.
Alter, das ist wirklich,
ey.
Das ist wirklich nicht so easy, mit den Dingern
zu treffen jetzt.
No joke, keckel.
Leute, echt,
echt nicht so einfach.
Das ist, das ist eine blöde Idee, hier rum zu rennen, oder?
Ist das, ist das eine gute oder eine schlechte Idee?
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Oder ist die Six Hand
und die rechnen nicht damit?
Alles, alles möglich.
Guck mal, jetzt machen sie das nach, hier.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Jo, jo, jo, jo, jo, jo, jo, jo, nice.
Pfeifer, Pfeifer.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Von wo, von wo?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, von wo.
Leute, ich hab ein Problem, ich weiß echt nicht wo.
Wo, wo, wo?
Ach, unter mir.
Lul.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung von wo, aber ich bin hier auch
total exposed auf dem Dach.
Sehr agil, ja.
Ja.
Daily Scrum war hier einfach auf dem Dach gerade.
Ich geh wieder aufs Dach.
Man muss das, man muss das ausnutzen, wenn man den Typ spielt.
Okay, wir sollten, oh shit.
Ich muss mal kurz hier liegen bleiben.
Es war klar, dass der
Sniper ist.
Easy.
Okay, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ich hab einen Smoke Launcher dabei.
Ach, wir haben es schon.
Ach, wir
haben, easy.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Dachte, wir beißen uns hier gerade die
Zähne aus, an einem Einen entkommen, aber
anscheinend nicht.
Ich muss vertikal skalieren,
nee.
Leute, also seriously,
cringe, also massive cringe,
wer überhaupt noch horizontal
oder vertikal skaliert. Ich hab's schon
oft hier im Stream gesagt,
richtig, richtig agilen, modernen
hippen Leute, die skalieren nur noch
diagonal, weil dann hast
du alles auf einmal.
Da hinter dem Baum steht doch einer.
What the fuck?
Sag mal.
Ach, der war hinter 30 Milliarden
Schildern.
Oh, was ist hier?
Warum ich den
nicht hätte?
Oh, oh, oh,
ganz schlechte Idee, ganz schlechte Idee.
Ich verpiss mich hier mal wieder.
Kann man hier drüber?
Da ist irgendein
Sniper, Dude. Du triffst mich nicht. Nein, nein, nein,
triffst mich nicht. Easy.
Dodged.
Easy dodge.
Horizontal skalieren. Nee, da kommst du ja wieder da an,
wo du aufgehört hast.
Okay, ich renn einfach mal vor. Ich hab
absolut keine Ahnung, wo irgendwelche Gegner sind.
Aber wir haben das M-Com.
Nice. Easy win.
Null gecheckt,
die Map beim ersten Mal spielen,
aber wir wurden gecarried
von Marichan.
Ah, ja, ja.
Marichan.
Nee, oder? Ach nee, Chain.
Ah.
Marichan wär mir lieber gewesen.
Ich muss mal kurz Chatge
lesen, während das...
Ja, lass mal gucken, was das Game der Meinung ist.
Elf Assault Rifle Kills.
Five at a time.
Die sind nur fünftes Squad. Ist ja mies.
So, Chatge,
war das die Battlefield 4 Map? Savot.
Ja, das war die Battlefield 4 Map.
Das war diese Fabrik Map.
Ich glaube Savot heißt sogar,
heißt sogar Fabrik,
Savot.
Institution. Ich dachte es heißt Fabrik.
Ach, das ist Slowenisch.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Russisch.
Anlage heißt es.
Anlage oder Fabrik.
Zu wenig Container.
Leute, ist euch aufgefallen?
Auf der neuen Map waren kaum Container.
Es waren dafür Zugwagons
an jeder Ecke.
Es waren weniger Container.
Just MX. Naja, ich auch.
Aber...
Eher aus dem Grund,
weil ich halt einfach mal Bock hätte, wieder ordentlich
Battlefield zu spielen.
Oh, was habe ich unlocked?
Extended Mag.
Oh.
Und ein LWG
Crip Collection.
Zeigt mal kurz her. Lass uns das mal
kurz attachen.
Extended. Okay, der Reload Speed
ist noch langsamer.
Okay, das ist natürlich
ernsthaft sehr pp-iger,
weil der Reload Speed ist jetzt schon
ziemlich lahm.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Wow.
Bipod braucht keiner.
Okay.
Wieder Reclaimed.
Nice. Nochmal die neue Map.
Da will ich mich ja mal nicht beschweren,
wenn wir Rush jetzt öfters mal die neue Map spielen
dürfen, bis man halbwegs durchblickt.
Sehr nice.
Poke... Uh.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Das sind so die...
Leute, wenn die...
Wenn die Underbarrels, ne?
Wenn die überhaupt
keinen
Unterschied machen,
dann kann man die doch auch
einfach mal dran machen.
Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen... Okay.
Ach, das ist ein Single-Shot-Shotgun.
Single-Shot-Shotgun.
Und das ist ne...
Was machen wir hiermit?
I'm moving.
Ne, das ist gut. Ich move hier
eigentlich fast immer. Barrel.
Suppressor.
Mini-Map-Stealth.
Okay, mal gucken.
Mal schauen, ob das was taugt.
Oh, es geht schon los.
Wait a minute.
Moment, die haben schon... Ja, geil.
Okay, wir machen jetzt mal die Shotgun dran.
Habt ihr einen Plan,
was ich für ein Shotgun drücken muss,
dass ich den Shot, dass ich das
ausrüsten kann?
Also...
Was muss ich drücken überhaupt dafür?
X?
X!
Okay, da wär ich nicht drauf gekommen.
Alpha Objective is down.
Okay, pass auf.
Die haben mich nicht gesehen. Sixer-Time.
Oh, oh, oh. Pass auf, der pusht mich.
Shit, da war einer von der Seite.
Sonst hätt ich den pre-fired.
Deadge gewesen. Richtig im Sarg
hergelegen.
So.
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir mit dem Silencer ein bisschen
Flank-Action machen können.
Ich...
Shit.
Das ist eine blöde Seite, da steht man zu offen.
Das ist nix.
Nixge.
Ist das.
Okay, okay, okay.
Achtung, Granate.
Ich hab hier dieses verfickte...
Ich hab das Wurfmesser.
Okay, das Wurfmesser ist nicht so...
nicht so geil hier jetzt.
Ich muss weg, ich muss weg, ich muss weg, ich muss weg.
Shit.
Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
MonkaS, MonkaS, MonkaS.
Okay.
Da kommen jetzt welche. Achtung.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob er da rauskommt
oder da raus.
Die müssen doch hier rauskommen jetzt.
Komm raus.
Alter, dudes, wo seid...
Okay, die haben keinen Bock.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf, was wir jetzt machen.
Wir machen jetzt exzellent Five-At-A-Time.
Oh ne, wollen wir nicht.
Es hätte klappen können.
Manchmal muss man es einfach
probieren, gerade als Defender, wo man keine
Ticket-Probleme hat.
Okay, wir sollten
auf jeden Fall hier hinten die abfangen.
Ah, ich kann nicht schießen.
Weil...
Die Nachlade-Animation ist ja ewig
bei dem Ding.
Passt mal auf, wie lang die ist.
Ah, shit.
Du denkst, die ist fertig
und in Wirklichkeit läuft die noch 2 Sekunden
länger.
Guck mal, guck mal. Man denkt, jetzt ist sie fertig,
aber jetzt ist sie fertig.
Moin.
Close, close.
Ich glaube, ich bin gar nicht am Gegner gestorben, sondern an...
Ne, ne, ne, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin in der Zone.
Request revive.
Guck mal, Medik.
Medik, ihr 2 da oben.
Medik.
Help.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
Ja, oh, nice.
Nice,
Dettke, next.
Wow, da hinten ist ganz schön was los.
Wir müssen... Das ist echt
nicht... Das ist echt gefährlich hier.
Passt mal auf, wir gehen jetzt rein.
Wir gehen rein.
Okay, das hat sich nicht gelohnt.
Ich bin Dettke.
Ich bin einfach komplett Dettke.
Nein, ich bin nicht Dettke.
Habt ihr gedacht, ich komm
Paxi raus? Ich nicht.
Hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht.
Passt mal auf, der wird gewurfmessert jetzt.
Was ein Gekämpe hier an der Ecke,
Mensch.
Smoke.
Die pushen jetzt durch, während Smoke ist.
Zumindest würde ich das an ihrer Stelle machen.
Sag ich doch.
Oh.
Squadkollege
hockt mit Sniper in der Base.
Leute, das ist doch Standard.
Das ist doch normal.
Dass die
mit Sniper in der Base hocken.
Okay, Dauerfeuer.
Das muss ich mir abgewöhnen.
Dauerfeuer ist echt nicht wirklich praktikabel.
Da liegt einer.
Das ist echt blöd.
Also, die Assault Rifles.
Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ich hab keinen Bock,
die ganze Zeit da rumzustehen in der Ecke.
Gehen wir mal.
Gehen wir mal hier gucken.
Gehen wir uns mal hier ein bisschen langstelzen
und schauen, was abgeht.
Vielleicht kriegen wir was von der Seite weg.
Sache ist nur die...
Oh, lege Hände.
Lege Hände.
Disable.
Easy.
Da kannst du mich auch ruhig snipen.
Das ist mir egal.
Snipe mich ruhig beim Defenden.
Solange du mich erst snipest, wenn ich defused habe, ist alles okay.
Was macht denn der Gang so?
Hier wird bestimmt
klare Glasfaser verlegt.
Oh, oh.
Was ist das?
Win.
Gigachat
Objective Players. So sieht es aus.
Guck mal, ich bin erster,
weil ich Objectives
das Abend habe.
HeyPotatoWed schreibt, wir haben einen Brief bekommen.
Wir kriegen kostenlos Glasfaser
in den Keller. Das ist nice.
Da wäre ich auch sofort dabei.
Wenn wir kostenlos Glasfaser kriegen.
Ich wäre sogar dabei,
wenn wir nicht kostenlos Glasfaser kriegen.
Ich wäre sogar bei paid Glasfaser dabei.
Hauptsache Glasfaser.
Und dann, wisst ihr was?
Dann Celebration
weg von Vodafone.
Wir wollen alle Glasfaser.
Na gut.
Das kann man so nicht sagen.
Die
Oma um die Ecke, die will wahrscheinlich
kein Glasfaser, weil die dann sagt,
so nach dem Motto, ach, ich benutze
das Internet doch so selten und ich
bin eh alt und ich bin eh langsam.
Da brauche ich doch gar nicht so
schnelles Internet. Ne, ne.
Dafür lass, dafür sollen die nicht
bei mir die Straße aufbuddeln. Dann will ich
lieber nix.
Das ist das, was sie nur nach 15
Oma oder nur nach 15 Opa in Deutschland
sagt, wenn es um Glasfaserausbau geht.
Was irgendwie auch nur ein Millimeter
seines, seines Grundstücks
tangiert. Briefe
schreiben, Brieftauben schicken.
Mal gucken, was ich...
Ah! Die Map
ist so top,
mal top, mal flop.
Ich wollte übrigens noch andere Attachments mal
checken.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Also haben wir, haben wir sonst noch irgendwie?
Ne, da gibt's, sonst gibt's
nix mehr. Was haben wir als Lauf?
Auch nix. Was
haben wir als Attachment? Haben wir noch irgendwas als
Attachment? Blind
Effect? Hör mal bloß
auf. Okay, mein
Ziel ist jetzt, ich sag euch
was wir machen. Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren,
wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich campe jetzt an einem der M-Comps
und wenn einer
kommt, dann kriegt er
ne M320
Shotgun-Ladung in your face.
Also sowas hier.
Sowas hier, guck.
X und dann BAM!
Und dann, okay. Also Leute,
das sollte besser ordentlich Damage
machen. Das ist Single,
das ist ne Single-Schuss-Shotgun mit ewig
langem Reload und
insgesamt nur drei Schuss.
Also, jetzt mal seriously, wenn das
nicht krassen Damage macht, dann ist es ja useless.
Oh, der Pantsman ist da.
Dann ist es...
Oh!
Ha! Ha! Ha!
Ist das schlecht?
Oh Gott, ist das schlecht?
Diffuse-Gear.
Also das Ding ist
aber richtig mies. Ich mein,
guck mal, ich hab drei Schuss
und so nen krassen Spread hat das
nicht. Und ich hab dem
Typ 5% Leben gemacht
oder abgezogen oder sowas.
Okay,
das ist hier aber ultra crap, man.
Probier das jetzt nochmal aus.
Oh! Oh!
Sehr schlau, Max. Richtig
Poggersplay.
Excellent Poggersplay.
Achtung! Volle Pulle!
PP-Radiffuse!
Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein! Nein!
Ah!
Was sind denn das für neue Granaten, die da angezeigt
werden?
Das war irgendeine neue
Granate. Das war nicht die normale.
Nee, da stand kein Geschütz.
Das war doch so ein Radar oder sowas.
Das war doch kein... War das ne Sentry-Gun
gerade?
Seht ihr mal, wie PP-geil ich bin. Ich blick noch nicht mal durch,
was ich überhaupt sehe.
Lul.
Ah, das war ein echtes Geschütz? Okay.
Ah, dann...
Ich dachte, das war irgendwie ein
Radar oder sowas.
Okay. Okay.
Alles klar.
Nice.
Oh, da drüben ist ein Gegner.
Das macht keinen Damage.
Fuck. Ich hab's probiert. Ich hab's probiert. Beide.
Hm. Ja, das ist nichts.
LMGs sind ganz gut.
Ich glaube, ich hab in dem Game
noch nie
ernsthaft LMGs
gespielt.
Sollte man vielleicht mal... Ich probier gleich noch mal ein anderes
Assault-Rifle aus.
Aber auch wieder
ein klassisches Battlefield-Reihe-Rifle.
Oder Battlefield 4. Eins von Beiden.
Ja, okay, nee. Als Defender
ist die... Sagt niemand.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Oh, nee. Da oben... Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Okay.
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Das ist keine normale
Granate oder SPH-Explosive-
Launcher.
RM-68 ist noch
OP. Was ist denn das? Ne SMG?
Oder... Was ist das?
What the...
Was ist denn das für ein Ding?
Oh, ist das für ein Teil.
Wir gammeln ein bisschen viel auf dem Dach, würde ich sagen.
Wir sind ein bisschen
zu krasse...
Dachgammler.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt hier runter.
Wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen.
Ich würde den gerne retzen.
Kann ich aber nicht.
Nahkampf! Geil.
Homeoffice ist Poggers. Aber ich bin heute
nicht im Homeoffice.
Der Respawn ist aber auch sehr, sehr...
Fuck!
Ich dachte, man kann reload...
Man kann schneller switchen.
Vielleicht ist er noch auf dem Dach. Jawohl!
Bester Dude auf dem Dach hier, der Typ.
Der ist nice.
Der Dachhocker.
Oh, oh.
Der wird sie alle wegstelzen mit der Pistole jetzt.
Alle.
Alle werden sie weggesprayt mit der Pistole von der Seite.
Als Attacker macht mir
die Map eigentlich Bock.
Das letzte Haus ist extrem nice.
Okay.
Leute, ich muss nochmal
diese komische Shotgun hier testen jetzt.
Wo ist es denn hier? Achtung, Shotgun.
Ey, das Ding ist
so mies.
Und es braucht ewig
zum Nachladen.
Leute, bevor ich diese Waffe
wechsle, ich brauch
ein Kill mit der Shotgun.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das Ding auch nur
irgendeiner Art und Weise was taugt.
Okay, okay.
Nehmen.
Nee, das ist ein Geschütz.
Okay, Geschütze
kann man damit anscheinend... Oh, oh.
Wo ist er? Wo ist der Dude?
Nice.
Wenn man nicht treffen kann, muss man sich auch nicht beschweren.
Da kann die Shotgun
jetzt nichts für.
Aber...
Es steht ja schon im Titel, ihr sollt euch
preparen for Pepega-Aim.
Okay, pass auf.
Messerkill, Messerkill. Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Messerkill.
Achtung, einen hab ich noch.
Oh shit, man.
Messerkill. Ein Shotgun?
Ziel für die Runde.
Shotgun-Kill?
Messerkill.
Ey, man. Alter.
Die Shotgun.
Okay,
ein Schuss noch.
Okay, das Ding ist einfach nur mies.
Das ist einfach nur Müll, die Shotgun, Alter.
Auf die Range
sollte die One-Shot... Okay, wir testen,
wir testen das andere.
Ähm...
Wir brauchen...
Dart ist ein bisschen Range.
Okay, das hier.
Nice, okay.
Bin mir nicht ganz
schlüssig, wo hier was ist.
Bam. Alter, sag mal.
Wollen die mich veräppeln?
Das Zeug macht ja überhaupt keinen Damage.
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
Shotgun.
Okay, die ist schon mal besser.
Die ist schon mal...
What the fuck? Die ist schon mal besser
als die Buckshot.
Als die M360 Buckshot.
Die geht schon irgendwie, okay?
Also damit kann man zumindest schon mal ein bisschen was killen.
Easy win, okay.
Hat anscheinend gereicht.
Nee, also die
Attachments, ich weiß nicht.
Ich mein, du brauchst ja eine Shotgun
an einem Assault Rifle, also
an einem Auto Assault Rifle.
Du brauchst ja daran keine Shotgun, die
im Nahkampf
quasi schlechter killt als das Assault Rifle
selbst. Also das ist nix.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist es...
Okay, Leute, es ist doch nicht blöd, das auszurüsten.
Weil so wie es aussieht,
hat die Waffe... Wir müssen die Griffe mal...
Wir müssen mal die Griffe checken, ja?
So wie es aussieht, als hat die Waffe keinen
sonderlich guten Attachments, so sind das
immerhin 18 Bonusschuss für eine Shotgun,
die man einfach noch dabei
bekommt. Das sind alles
echte Spieler, das waren keine Bots.
Man denkt das vielleicht
bei manchen, oder bei
mir auch zwischendurch manchmal.
Aber nee, nee,
das sind keine... Wie aktiviert
man denn XP-Boni?
Okay, im Booster.
Ja, close.
Ach, ich hab...
Aktivieren die sich automatisch?
Weil eben waren es nur noch 23 Minuten.
Ich glaub, die aktivieren sich.
Die sind leider direkt aktiv.
Sieht man mal auch wieder den Rückschritt von Battlefield 4.
Battlefield 4, konntest du sagen,
ey, ich hab jetzt mal 5, 6 Stunden
Zeit, kann richtig hardcore grinden.
Dann hast du deinen XP-Booster angemacht.
Oder auch die Waffenbooster an den...
Wenn du für die Waffen...
Wieder! Beste! Nice!
DLC-Map.
Oder, naja, DLC... Nein, nicht DLC.
Season-Map.
Mal gucken, was wir jetzt sind.
Lass mal eine andere Waffe ausprobieren.
BF3 aber. A1-4-90.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zum attachen?
Ähm...
Ein Suppressor?
Okay.
Und Griffke.
Will ich...
gar kein Griffke haben.
Griffke, alter.
Extended Mag?
Und was haben wir denn hier?
Holo? Nee, das ist okay so.
Ach, es geht schon los!
Okay, machen wir mal Suppressor dran.
Das da und Code-Ravies hier.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Na, geil! Beste! Reingespawnt,
Attachments drauf, kommst und du schon um die Ecke
geflitzt.
Okay, es scheint mir so ein bisschen
Flank-Action auf B zu gehen.
Deswegen stellen wir uns mal
kurz hier lang.
Die kommen garantiert wieder über die...
Die Bahn kommt da vorne gerade.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Es hat kaum Damage gemacht, Lul.
What the...
Was denn?
Die suckt.
Die suckt auf Range extrem
mit dem Schalldämpfer.
Kannst vergessen.
Äh...
Ähm...
Ich hab Schiss.
Ich verpiss mich mal hier kurz.
Na gut, aber wir machen...
Ne, die suckt mit Silencer.
Die kann man nicht spielen mit Silencer.
Das ist Müll.
Das ist Müll mit Silencer.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Die kannst du nicht spielen mit Silencer.
Die macht viel zu wenig Damage und viel zu viel rumgewackelt auf Range.
Die müssen wir ohne Silencer spielen.
Ähm...
Ja, es ist nicht schlecht, wenn sie dich nicht sehen. Das stimmt schon.
Also wenn sie dich auf dem Radar nicht sehen, aber...
What the...
Aber die andere ist besser. Die andere ist auf jeden Fall besser.
Für Stealth-Action.
Guck mal, wie ewig das dauert, man.
Ich hör was rennen übrigens.
Hier neben uns. Oh, oh.
Okay, der könnte mich retzen.
Der ist direkt neben mir. Der hat auch keine Sicht.
Keine Sicht auf den.
Retzke.
Jawohl, Medic.
Alter, Medic, Oma.
Okay, ich seh hier grad nix.
Die ist wirklich nix mit Silencer.
Ne, das Ding ist...
Das Ding ist übelst...
M48. Äh, 68.
Was ist denn das für eine?
Ist das ein SMG? Ist das ein Assault Rifle?
Man erkennt das bei den Dingern nicht.
Äh.
Ich mach den Schalldämpfer ab.
Das gefällt mir. Die Kombi gefällt mir nicht.
Das andere war ganz nice,
aber das war nix. So.
Ohne Silencer
ist die eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay, nice.
Irgendwo hier ist was. Ich seh bloß nicht genau wo.
Kurz Kopf.
Ne, das sind meine Dudes.
Was ist denn die letzte Waffe?
Leute, ich hab das letzte nicht richtig gespielt,
weil mein Spiel nicht gestartet ist.
Aber geht jetzt ja anscheinend wieder.
50%.
Oh, da war was. Da ist was. Da ist was.
Shit.
Alter, die Assault Rifles, die sind ja mal auf Range.
Das ist richtig mies.
Oh, da war noch mehr. Ich hab's.
Shit. Die hätte ich alle haben können.
Der kommt zu mir.
Reload. Reload.
Der ist unter mir eingehört und wollte mich rumdrehen.
Aber immerhin. Also das Ding geht ohne Silencer
ganz gut, klar.
Aber mit Silencer... Oh, die haben das auch noch.
R? Okay, wo gibt's die?
R?
RM68.
Ist das ein Assault Rifle?
Ne, ne? Was ist denn das?
Ach ne, hier seh ich ja
nur die Anlockten.
Ich hab die nicht angelockt.
Ist das... Chat, Chat, ich hab's
immer noch nicht gecheckt. Ist das ein Assault Rifle?
Hä? Ist das ein Assault Rifle?
Ah, ja.
Okay.
Dann muss ich mal kurz gucken, klein nach der Runde,
was man da anlocken kann.
Ab und zu muss man auch mal ein bisschen OP-Zeug spielen.
Wie gesagt, letzte Season konnte ich nicht spielen.
Da ist mein Game einfach nicht gestartet.
Oder nicht, richtig.
Wo sind die?
Wo ist denn hier was? E-Richtung A.
Okay, der...
Sagt doch,
preparet euch für härtestes
PP-Ger-Aim.
Aber gut.
Jetzt wissen wir zumindest auf welcher Seite sie pushen.
Geht gut was an A ab.
Ich wär auch gerne mal wieder
Attacker. Das macht mir einfach mehr Bock.
Ah, shit.
Das ist nix.
Ich glaub, ich schwenk wieder um auf die M416.
M416.
Welche waren das jetzt hier?
Gut, das haben sie.
Jetzt können wir die Shotgun rausholen.
Okay.
Ich mein, es ist ganz nice,
eine Shotgun dabei zu haben für sowas.
Oh, wir müssen unbedingt auf B rüber.
Vielleicht komm ich hier nochmal rein.
Aber ich glaub's nicht.
Wir müssen unbedingt auf B rüber.
Die Cluster-Granate.
Die haben sie doch genervt. War da nicht was?
Wurde die nicht irgendwie angepasst?
Ich glaube, die Cluster...
Nee, die Cluster-Granate selbst ist glaube ich noch...
Oh, nice. Ich dachte, da ist ein Dach.
Die Cluster-Granate ist noch das gleiche, aber
wie oft man die benutzen...
Okay, und tschüss.
Ich möchte aufs Dach hoch.
Nice.
Okay.
Wenn ich...
Komm raus.
Komm raus. Ich weiß, dass du dahinter bist.
Kollege.
Wir müssten Diffuse-Gear machen.
Diffuse-Gear müssen wir machen.
Aber...
Okay, nicer Dude.
Five-Header.
Die hätte ich sprayen können.
Hätte ich ein paar Sekunden
länger Zeit gehabt.
Das hätten einfach fünf Leute an der Nase.
Na gut, da kannst du nichts machen,
wenn du vor drei Gegnern stehst.
Direkt in Sichtlinie.
Nice. Immerhin.
An mir liegt's nicht.
Geh mal schauen.
Hier zu campen ist glaube ich eine echt bescheuerte Idee.
Wir können hier auch absolut null
vorpushen, weil die...
Weil die Grenze
von der Map halt so ungünstig
für uns gelegen ist.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es eigentlich ganz gut,
weil sonst könntest du hier halt spawn-raiten
ohne Ende.
Ey, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Okay, man muss auf jeden Fall
tappen. Sonst ist man...
Wenn man das nicht tappt auf mittlere Range,
ist man richtig gefickt.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, ich weiß, wo du bist.
Fuck. Von der Seite.
Immer da, wo man nicht hinguckt.
Krieg ich ein Rats?
Oh, Oma, Oma. Jawohl, Medic, Oma.
Rats, jawohl, jawohl.
Dimas.
Jawohl. Nee, oder noch besser hier.
Niko. Pogu.
Richtiger Poggers-Dude, ey.
MVP Niko am Start.
Richtiger Macher,
wie man das so schön sagt heutzutage.
Oh, mein Bein.
Du spielst nur die Rats, Oma.
Ich mag den...
Der Reload ist
viel zu lang. Finde ich auch.
Das wirkt nicht nur so.
Gerade mit Extended Mag, das dauert ewig,
bis du da reloadet hast.
Hallo?
Treffen, please.
Ja gut, rennt ihr nur
schön an mir vorbei, ohne zu gucken, Mann.
Rechte Seite geht's
wohl eher ab gerade.
Shit, zu spät gesehen.
Pega29.
Taugt das Ding mittlerweile
wieder was? Ist das wieder gut?
Das war ja die OP-Waffe überhaupt
in der ersten...
in den ersten paar Wochen.
Oh shit.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo er ist. Welche Seite?
Da ist noch einer.
Da ist auf jeden Fall noch einer.
Ich hör einen über mir. Ich muss da jetzt...
Nice.
Nein! Fuck it.
Ah, da ist noch einer. Shit.
Weil ich hab hinter mir einen gehört.
Den hätte ich auf jeden Fall nicht mehr erwischt.
Ich muss jetzt da rüber. Ich dachte nicht, dass da noch ein Zweiter ist.
Aber da machst du nix.
Kann ich nicht retten.
Oder? Doch, kann ich.
Gib ihm.
Nice.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich hau da mal ab. Von wo? Von wo?
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Manchmal muss man ein bisschen
den Stelzmodus aktivieren im Battlefield.
Manchmal geht's halt anders.
Okay, okay.
Sehr gut, Max.
Mehr Pepega
aimt. Ich weiß nicht...
Ihr wisst aber auch nicht, wo ich bin, ne?
Lulbe.
Keckel. Extreme.
Oh, shit.
Das war ja was, man.
Wir haben uns
gerade übertroffen im Pepega aim.
Das war jetzt Pepega aim
World Championship gerade.
Blöde Idee, Max.
Ganz blöde Idee.
Ganz blöde Idee, ganz blöde Idee, ganz schlechte Idee.
Pepega aim
World Championship, aber wirklich
ganz krass.
War da unter mir einer?
Ah, shit. Immer der,
wo man nicht hinguckt.
Hä? Immer...
Das ist...
Das ist die Battlefield-Regel, Leute.
Es bäscht dich immer
der, den du nicht siehst.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Oh, Reds, Reds.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll. Nice.
Spritze in Bobbes.
Kann ich das noch
diffusen?
Nice.
Okay, also wenn ich jetzt nicht Top-Kills kriege,
in der
Endgame-Statistik,
dann bin ich beleidigt.
Ich kriege jetzt bestimmt ein Shotgun-Kill
oder sowas komisches.
Okay, objective play, alles gut.
Revives, objective, auch okay, auch okay.
Top-Kills? Ja,
wenigstens...
wenigstens einmal.
Career-Best, Leute.
Wir haben das
High-Performer-Mindset offensichtlich gerade
aktiviert. Ich hatte aber sogar...
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass das Career-Best
ist. Ich hatte
sogar schon Videos auf YouTube, da hatte ich
deutlich mehr Assault-Rifle-Kills pro Runde.
Das ist ja auch nur eine Rush-Runde. Eine Rush-Runde
geht ja auch viel kürzer. Aber ich hatte
schon Runden auf YouTube mit
mehr Kills. Ich hatte, glaube ich,
eine 54-Kill-Runde Rush.
Vielleicht mit der Waffe
auf der Map in der Kombination oder sowas.
Jetzt geht die Progression, Leute!
Die Progression, die richtig
High-Performed...
Nee, das sah aus, als wären es zwei Level
oder drei Level, aber es war nur
eins.
Guck mal jetzt... Ach ja, genau.
Collection...
KQ-46, das Ding...
Na, okay.
Ähm...
RM-68
Unlock. Was muss man dafür machen?
Leute, wie ist eigentlich
die Stream-Qualität und
die...
wie flüssig das ist und sowas?
Ich hab die Bandbreite hochgestellt.
Also es sollte wirklich
keine großen
Artefakte geben.
Battle Pass Tier
40. Ah, okay.
Aber der aktuelle
Battle Pass auch oder der letzte
Battle Pass? Aber man wird das ja
mit Sicherheit noch unlocken können.
Ja gut, aber
diesen vier Battle Pass gibt's doch
nicht mehr. Oder kann man die
nachträglich irgendwie machen noch?
Ich bin mega planlos,
was das angeht.
Wir müssen mal schauen gleich. Erinnert mich
mal, please, nach der Runde dran,
dass ich noch mal gucke,
wie man das macht, wie man die unlockt
jetzt. So, die pushen garantiert auf A
erstmal. Deswegen gehen wir auf A,
weil auch... Okay, nein.
Ihr habt nix gesagt.
Ja, ich guck gleich mal in die Sammlung.
Ja, so machen wir das.
Vielleicht geh ich auch einfach aus der Runde raus.
Erste Base hier ist
immer Pepega
extremly...
Schon Bebega ist das schon.
Okay, nice.
Oh, da ist einer.
Ja, geiler
Schneiber-Dude, man.
Oh, da ist noch einer.
Chat, war das Boomer Augen oder
habt ihr den auch nicht gesehen?
Kombination wahrscheinlich.
Du hast den auch nicht gesehen.
Au.
Okay. Alter,
sag mal.
Du machst hier ja gar nix,
außer verrecken.
Da hinten ist übrigens einer, oder?
What?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch, wo grad was abgeht.
Ich geh jetzt einfach mal hier hin,
guck da mal um die Ecke
und freu mich, dass hier...
Da war einer übrigens links.
Easy.
Oder auch nicht.
Das sind jetzt wirklich ESL
Final Lobbys wieder, ja.
Das ist wirklich ESL Finals.
Eigentlich sollte ich
auf Engineer switchen, dass wir die Dinger
platt machen können, aber
das ist gar nicht so notwendig,
weil wir können das alles wieder
wettmachen in der Fabrik gleich.
Alles kein Ding.
Okay.
Wir können das in der Fabrik alles wieder...
Aber ich hab die RM68
nicht unlockt, Leute.
Hab ich doch grade gesagt.
Ich konnte letzte Season das Game nicht spielen,
weil ich das Game nicht starten konnte.
Weil DICE sich gedacht hat,
nee, der Max, der hat das Game gekauft
und will das spielen,
aber das geht nicht.
Der basht zu sehr.
Alter Tryhard basht junge Noobs
und das wollen wir nicht.
Das ist nicht...
Da war.
Woran häng ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Schnitzel.
Ey, da hätt ich mal richtig Bock drauf
wieder, Leute.
Okay, nice.
Da hätt ich mal richtig Bock drauf.
Schnitzel, Zwiebel,
Blattkartoffel.
Da hätt ich
massiv Bock drauf.
Sag ich euch.
Okay.
Ich hab extrem Bock drauf.
Okay, wir gehen
jetzt mal hier hinter,
weil ich die kleinen PP-Gas kenne.
Was?!
Lege Henne!
Jetzt schon!
Shit. Okay, das wird schwierig,
die Runde. Das ist wirklich ESL Finals jetzt.
Wo sind wir hier eigentlich?
Wo bin ich denn hier? Hier war ich ja
ernsthaft noch nie.
Wo bin ich?
Ich will zu den M kommen.
Wo bin ich überhaupt?
Okay.
Alter! Schlaganfall-Time.
Ne?
Das Game hat nicht nur random
nicht gestartet.
nicht gestartet, das hat gar nicht gestartet.
Das hat einfach Season 4
nicht gestartet.
Wir haben es doch sogar im Stream hier ausprobiert.
Es ging einfach nicht.
Es ist einfach nicht gestartet.
Sogar nicht gestartet.
Einfach gar nicht. Was war denn das?
Habt ihr das grad...
Habt ihr das grad fliegen sehen an mir vorbei?
Was war das denn?
War das irgendeine Radar?
Aufklärungsdrohne?
Ich hab so keine Ahnung mehr von dem Game.
Gut, ich mein, es ist ja auch nicht so,
als hätte ich es wahnsinnig viel gespielt.
100 Stunden. Das ist halt nix
für Battlefield.
Also bei normalen Spielzeilen.
Was Battlefield-Games angeht.
Die ganze Runde Breakthroughs.
Stimmt, du hast recht. Das machen wir gleich.
Wir unlocken gleich die Waffe.
Ja, gute Idee. Chatge.
Pfeiffer-Time.
Richtig Pfeiffer.
Wir unlocken gleich alles.
Okay, fuck. Ich dachte, er ist dead.
Letzter dead.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung. Hier noch einer.
Oh, oh, oh shit.
Da läuft noch einer.
Nice.
By the way, den hab ich nicht richtig gesehen.
Okay, nice.
Das ist...
Sobald mich der Tank sieht, bin ich fucked.
So richtig.
So richtig fucked.
Okay, jetzt.
Jetzt bin ich dead.
Aber wir haben doch wirklich...
Ich glaub, wir haben grad 5 Stück oder so gekillt.
Da sollten sich jetzt wenigstens Brage
und das M-Com legen.
Oh, oh. Hinter mir.
Okay, das wird schwierig,
da wieder fortzukommen.
Okay, okay. Wo kommt er? Wo kommt er?
Okay, die wissen, dass ich da bin.
Auf jeden Fall.
Rechts? Links?
Oh, Alter.
Please. Sniper-Shit, Mann.
Was soll das?
Den Kill hat er nicht verdient.
Ich hab den im Rennen schon abgeballert.
Und dann macht der irgendeinen komischen Hüften-
Scope-Shit.
Was ein Müll.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Ich camp hier jetzt mit der Shotgun.
What the hell?
Der Typ, Mann.
Jetzt rennt der da auch
mit der Shotgun rum, Alter.
Hab ich die auch?
Ist das eine Pistole?
Leute, ist das eine Pistole, die Mini-Shotgun?
Oh, oh.
Wir sind dead.
Oh, wir sind so was von dead.
Das ist eine Pistole.
Okay, das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Ich muss anlocken gleich.
Rm86 und Shotgun-Pistole.
Okay, defeat.
Moment.
Das ist nicht die letzte Base normalerweise?
Ist das jetzt neuerdings die letzte Base?
Outstanding Kills.
Jawohl.
Okay, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Das müssen wir gleich mal checken.
Gehen wir mal aus der Queue hier raus.
Mit 1700 FPS.
Habe ich den unlockt?
Gar nicht.
Zeigt mal, ist da irgendwas Spannendes,
was ich unlockt hab für das Ding?
M?
Wo ist es denn?
M416.
Ach, das ist gar kein Suppressor.
Den hier hab ich bloß noch zum unlocken.
Okay.
Also, okay.
Wo gibt es das Teil zum unlocken?
Rm68.
Man braucht Kills and Assists
mit M5A3.
Headshot. Easy.
Das haben wir ja
Null Komma nix.
M516.
Wir spielen ne Runde M5...
Nee, nicht M516.
M5A3. Dann haben wir das unlockt.
So, und wo ist die Shotgun-Pistole?
Super 500.
Was ist das?
Man braucht Kills with Shotguns.
Kriegen wir auch easy?
Nee, nee. Kills with Secondary Weapons.
Und Kills and Assists
with Shotguns.
Dann brauche ich wahrscheinlich ernsthaft das Ding, oder?
Es gibt ja nur eine Shotgun in dem Spiel.
Ah, nee. Das gibt es auch noch.
Ja, das wird...
Das wird abfuckt.
Aber man braucht zum Glück nicht viel.
Man braucht zum Glück nicht viel.
Ja, easy.
Das geht sehr zackig.
Also, wir brauchen 30 Kills
mit Shotguns.
Das ist innerhalb von 2-3 Minuten
haben wir das fertig.
5 Minuten haben wir das fertig.
Und wir brauchen, was hatte ich gesagt?
Ach, easy.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Leute, wenn ihr euch fragt, wie man Sachen unlockt,
am besten so.
Easy as fuck.
Das dauert 5 Minuten.
Dann haben wir das freigeschaltet.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt es euch gemerkt,
weil ich habe es mir nicht gemerkt.
25 oder 30 Shotgun-Kills.
30, oder?
30. Okay, easy.
Eats.
Eats 30 Shotgun-Kills.
Zählt das auch als Shotgun? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, und Secondary-Kills.
Und das andere waren
25 M5A3-Kills.
Ja?
Naja, das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Easy.
In South Korea sind wir.
Autoshotgun.
Stimmt, die habe ich auch noch nicht freigespielt.
Ich spiele halt eigentlich nur die Dinger frei.
Ach, Secondary-Kills über 25 Meter.
Kriege ich auch hin.
Ich spiele halt eigentlich
so gut wie nie Shotguns in dem Game.
Ich finde es auch meistens nicht sinnvoll,
wenn die Sniper-Challenges und Shotgun-Challenges
machen, weil das sind eh beide schon
mit die größten Abfuck-Waffen
in dem Game.
Das ist,
gerade wenn man Rush spielt,
ziemlich lehmt
so eine Runde, wenn du dann irgendwie
erstmal 90 Leute,
90% des Teams, die da sitzen
und in der Base und irgendwie ihre
360-Sniper-Challenge machen.
Wobei, gibt es den Trick
überhaupt noch? Sich aufs Dach
legen und die Beine der Gegner wegbashen?
Ich glaube, das geht gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist...
Ist das über 25 Meter
jetzt?
Sekunde, wir müssen mal kurz hier ran
und ein paar Gegner killen.
Okay.
Okay, das dauert doch länger, als ich gedacht habe. Vielleicht machen wir das doch nicht.
Ich muss da ein bisschen...
Ich muss da ein bisschen näher dran.
Aber es geht schnell.
Was ich übrigens auch sehr merkwürdig finde,
dass das Anlocken...
Dass das...
Dass das Anlocken gegen Bots funktioniert, by the way.
Guck mal, wir haben schon ein Drittel. Easy.
Geht das?
Brauche ich denn mal Muni?
Ah.
Okay, die Hälfte haben wir schon.
Das geht wirklich schnell, Leute.
Die Hälfte der Shotgun-Kills haben wir schon.
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich,
ich finde, das stellt ein bisschen...
Also dann sollten sie die Unlocks weglassen.
Ganz ehrlich, was ist der Sinn von Unlocks,
wenn du es einfach in zwei Minuten gegen Bots machen kannst?
Dann kannst du die Unlocks weglassen.
Alternativ, wenn du sagst, es dauert zu lang
gegen echte Spieler, sollte man die Unlocks
irgendwie herunterschrauben. Ich finde das vom Design her
einfach nur pipega hängen geblieben.
Versteht ihr, wie ich meine?
Also wenn du Unlocks machst, dann halt nur gegen echte Spieler.
Warum gegen Bots? Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Weil dann geht jeder in die Bots,
in die Bot-Matches rein und spielt dann
fünf Minuten Bot-Match und hat die Sachen unlockt.
Damit du Elite kaufst.
Ja, stimmt. Leute, wisst ihr, was dumm ist?
Ihr habt recht.
Ihr habt...
Ihr habt wahrscheinlich komplett recht.
Das ist irgend so ein DLC-
Anreizkauf-Shit.
Okay, Range-Kills.
Oh, nice, nice.
Krasses Aim, oder, Leute?
Krassestes Aim ever.
Krassestes Aim.
Besser geht das nicht.
Mehr ist es einfach top.
Absolut peak.
Aiming peak.
Okay, das sollten die 25-Meter-Kills sein.
Alter!
Okay, die Shotgun sackt im Range.
Okay, acht Kills noch, dann haben wir es.
Ja, das war schon seit Release so.
Okay, ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
auf was du dich beziehst im Chat.
Aber ich meine nur, weil Sachen seit Release so sind,
heißt ja nicht, dass es auch automatisch
geil ist.
Guck mal, ob du tatsächlich Fortschritt beim
Unlocken machst. Mach ich.
Ich weiß, die Bots zählen.
Definitiv, weiß ich.
Ich sehe gerade nichts.
Wo sind...
Gegners.
Okay, gleich haben wir es, Leute.
Und dann noch 25 Kills.
Okay, oh shit.
Noch drei Kills mit der Shotgun.
War das gestern ein Bug?
Es wäre in der Tat
sehr doof, wenn das nicht zählen würde.
Wisst ihr, ob die
Unlocks angezeigt werden?
Wenn man die
freigeschaltet hat, werden die Ingame angezeigt,
oder erst, wenn man
aus der Runde rausgeht.
Gibt es kurzes...
Okay, dann achtet mal kurz drauf,
ob das angezeigt wird.
Wurde gerade was
angezeigt?
Gab es ein Overlay?
Okay, das müsste
jetzt auf jeden Fall reichen.
Das müsste reichen.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch 25 Kills.
Ach, man kann direkt
hier in der Collection...
Ach, Chat, MVP.
Wo ist es denn hier?
Ja.
Aber in Shotguns wollte ich gucken.
Yep, nice.
Okay, wir brauchen noch...
Gott, easy, haben wir.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch 25 Kills
mit der M5A3.
Keine Ahnung, was man da am besten ausrüstet.
Eben nicht gespielt.
Also es heißt, wir haben 48...
Okay, sagen wir mal 50.
75. Okay.
Drei, vier Minuten, dann haben wir das auch.
Jaja, ist gut.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Das Ding...
Sag mal, das Ding verzieht null, oder?
Verzieht halt einfach gar nicht.
Im Vergleich zu M416.
Das ist einfach komplett
statisch. Ist das verbuggt?
Guck mal, Leute.
Das ist einfach komplett statisch.
Statical.
Nice, sehr gutes Aim.
So, gleich zehn Stück
noch.
Dann haben wir alles unlockt.
Das verzieht wirklich gar nicht.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das Absicht ist.
Einfach hier mal sitzen bleiben.
Der GG eats.
Bots, ja.
Ah ja, ich will anlocken.
Besser...
Besser als drei Stunden spielen
jetzt erstmal, bis ich die Sachen
ausprobiert hab.
Okay, haben wir es? Nee, ach Mist.
Range Kill?
Wollen wir einen Range Kill?
Range Kill brauchen wir noch.
Der hat keinen Bock mehr.
Okay, fünf Kills noch. Dann haben wir es geschafft.
Ist halt das Ding, wirklich Spaß machen
gegen Bots, tut's nett.
Aber besser als drei Stunden spielen.
Okay, nice.
Sehr gutes Ding
mit der Pistole.
Okay, Range Kill.
Zählt das? Ich hoffe.
Meint ihr, das waren 25 Meter?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich unlocke nur.
Leute, ich spiele nicht absichtlich
jetzt hier gegen Bots, weil ich denke,
wir haben schon auch... Das ist die erste Runde
gegen Bots, um schnell Unlocks zu machen.
Unlock...
Wir haben es gleich.
Noch drei Kills.
Wo wollen die eigentlich gerade hin?
Ah!
Die wollen zum Spawn
zurück, weil irgendwie das Game ihnen sagt.
Okay, der hier.
25 Meter, oder?
25 Meter?
Okay, wir sollten's haben.
Ich mache jetzt noch drei Bonus Kills
oder so. Wobei, wie war das?
Escape? Collection?
Wie?
Ach, Moment!
25 Meter
or less?
Chat, was habt ihr mir da wieder für Zeug erzählt?
Okay, das Ding haben wir.
Richtig,
richtig pepega Chat wieder.
Okay.
25 or less?
Ja, meine Güte!
So, jetzt haben wir alles unlockt gleich.
Ich hätte es schon
letzt gehabt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder?
Hat es jetzt gezählt?
Das war jetzt unter 25... Jawoll!
Nice! Easy! Okay, dann mal kurz
Equippen.
Nee, nicht Equippen, einfach rausgehen. Fertig.
Jawoll!
Weiter geht's. Rusch!
Siehste, wie lange hat es jetzt gedauert, Leute?
Zehn Minuten? Höchstens.
Und das ist halt das, was ich meine.
Wenn du Unlocks in das Game einbaust,
das ist ja
schön und gut. Ich meine, viele Leute,
ich bräuchte es nicht, ich hätte nichts dagegen, wenn alles
direkt accessible wäre.
Aber wenn du Unlocks in das Game einbaust,
dann sollte es echt nur gegen echte Spieler
funktionieren.
Weil sonst machen die Leute es so wie ich.
Die gehen in ein Boardgame,
spielen fünf bis zehn Minuten und
unlocken, was auch bescheuert ist.
Also entweder gibst du den Leuten
einfach alles oder du
packst alles an einen Battle Pass, meinetwegen.
Ich hätte auch keine
Probleme damit, wenn das alles unlockt ist.
Also ich meine, früher, in den Games
war es ja am meisten so, dass
die Waffen an Level gebunden
waren, sonst nix.
Das finde ich okay.
Ja, das finde ich okay.
Ich meine, gut, könntest du sagen,
ja, machst du halt XP-Grinds
versus Bots, gibt's bestimmt
immer noch irgendwelche Portal-Server, wo das
total easy geht, dass du massig XP machst.
Ja.
Ich sehe das ähnlich wie
Meester P, also wenn das
Game langweilig ist,
ohne Unlocks,
dann ist das Game wahrscheinlich kacke.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ein Game motivierend
ist, es kann durchaus cool
sein, wenn du ein paar Sachen unlocken
kannst. Ich persönlich finde es ja besser,
wenn du irgendwelche coolen
Gimmicks unlocken kannst, ja.
Leider werden heute halt alle Gimmicks in irgendwie
Och.
Ich finde, Caspian Border funktioniert in Battlefield
2042 nicht
richtig. Also ich meine,
guckt euch beispielsweise mal an, in CoD 4
war es mega nice, wenn du
beispielsweise, ah nice, die Runde ist vorbei.
Easy.
Ne, fuck, die geht jetzt jetzt los.
Fand ich es mega
nice, wenn man
die goldene Desert Eagle, goldene
LMG und so Zeug unlockt hat.
Okay, das Ding ist jetzt, das Ding ist
OP-AF oder wie ist das? Sehe ich das
richtig. Und wir machen jetzt hier mal
Gib mir die Shotgun.
Ich glaube, groß zu attachen.
Ah, die hat standardmäßig einen Schalldämpfer
drauf und Lasert. Ja, das ist natürlich
schon mal
Pog
Pog-G ist das.
Gibt es
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, mehr Schuss?
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Oh, Igitt, was ist denn?
Was ist das
für ein Visier? Das will ich nicht spielen.
Lasst mich mal
kurz, lasst mich mal kurz wipen
und dass ich ein anderes Visier picken kann.
Jawoll, schieß mich.
Mach mich kaputt. Jawoll, Pog, danke.
Anderes Visier, please.
Wobei, ne, dafür hätte ich gar nicht sterben müssen.
Ich kann nur
äh
Wie jetzt? Gibt es nicht?
Hat die, hat die nur so
Müllvisiere oder was?
Ja, Fusion
ein bisschen holo, wenn schon, denn schon
irgendwann mal.
Ein und seit kann man mit F, seht ihr mal?
Ihr blickt richtig, richtig Poggers
durch.
Das ist jetzt aber auch nicht viel schöner.
Das irritiert mich ja extrem.
Wenn ich so, wenn ich so spielen muss.
Äh, ich muss
eigentlich
müsste ich jetzt noch mal 30 Kills oder so
machen mit Bots für das
für das andere Visier.
Moment, sind die schon?
Die haben schon die Legehände gemacht.
Die haben schon gelegt.
Nice.
By the way, ich finde, die Map funktioniert nicht in dem Game.
Ich glaube, der ist mit
seinem Kopf selbst in die Bullets reingerannt gerade.
Sind
eigentlich, äh, das ist auch was.
Ähm,
sind Jets und Helis jetzt
eigentlich immer noch auf dem gleichen Slot?
Sodass eigentlich
dein Team
nur
abfuckst, wenn du überhaupt einen
Jet pickst.
Da ist noch einer drin, oder?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, ich spring da jetzt rein
und der Dude steht hier.
Aber ist nicht so.
So, wo sind die jetzt?
Sind die an A?
Die sind an A.
Okay.
Die mag ich nicht.
Die hat eine krasse Trauma-Frange.
Krieg ich den Reds?
Reds, please.
Jawoll, Oma.
Dankeschön.
Aber es ist gut.
Ehrlich gesagt, es ist
gut, dass die Shotgun nur so kurze Range hat.
Der hat mich jetzt ein bisschen
genervt, weil ich gerade nichts gekillt habe.
Ganz im Ernst, stellt euch mal vor, die Shotgun würde
da hinten irgendwie am
würde da hinten am
Baum irgendwie einen hitten oder so.
Wäre auch bescheuert.
Ich sollte mich mal kurz
Oh, da ist einer gedroppt.
Droppt.
Oh, da kommt noch einer.
Muss mal kurz hier abcampen.
Keiner mehr da.
Gehen wir mal zu A.
Aber B, B, B, B, B.
Wo ist er? Ist er im...
Ey.
Ich dachte, er ist im Bus.
Der war doch, der war doch da hinten.
Die Fuske.
Die Fuske, nice.
Denkst du es noch mal an
wirklich letztes Berlin?
Ach, ich glaube schon. Vielleicht, Leute.
Ich glaube, wir hatten ja ein paar ganz brauchbare Szenen.
Na, nice.
Wir hatten ja ein paar ganz brauchbare Szenen heute
im Stream bis jetzt schon.
Also vielleicht
schneide ich da irgendwas draus zusammen.
Liegt da einer.
Okay, muss ich sagen,
in dem Fall hat sich das Visier doch mal
gelohnt. Auch wenn ich, wenn ich diese
die A-Cock
Visiere nicht mag.
Pass auf.
Gebanen wir jetzt.
Oh.
Lege. Diffuse, Henne.
Gib ihm.
Win.
12-1, nice.
Yep, A-Cock.
Mal gucken, ob ich
eine Würdigung in den Credits
bekomme.
Alles gut.
Outstanding
Performer. Nein, wie?
Das war der falsche
Name.
Das...
Da stand ein anderer Name dran, aber mit
meiner Killanzahl.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ja, da stand...
Ist Renix überhaupt in dem Game drin?
Ach hier, der Dritte.
Auch 12. Ach das...
Guck mal, der hat eine bessere K.D.
Als ich.
Okay, fair, fair. Ist okay.
Ist gut. In Ordnung.
Ich hatte zwar insgesamt mit
paar Diffuses und so, finde ich, die bessere
Runden-Performance, aber ich will mich jetzt mal nicht
so sehr beschweren.
A-Holo, Beste.
Müssen wir gleich, müssen wir gleich Equip.
Gleich Equippen.
Wissen wir, mit zwei Kills auf dem zweiten Platz,
der ist wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit im Kreis gerushed
und hat Leute wiederbelebt.
Vermutlich. Oder...
Es war einer von den Panzer-Dudes.
Oder der
Heli. Vielleicht war das auch...
Nee, der Heli war im Attacker-Team.
Im Helipilot.
Finde ich auch gut. Irgendwie muss es ja auch einen Anreiz
geben für die Leute,
Panzer zu reparieren. Wobei, ganz ehrlich,
wie oft...
Jetzt mal Real Talk.
Sagt mal ehrlich, wie oft habt ihr
in Battlefield 2042 gesehen,
dass niemand
Panzer repariert hat?
Also ich kann mich an
keinen Vorfall erinnern.
Vielleicht unbewusst
3-4 Mal, wenn es hochkommt.
In dem Spiel repariert niemand Panzer.
Keiner.
Das Holo ist deutlich besser.
Ja, aber ich hab das Holo noch nicht unlockt.
Das, ähm...
Kommt irgendwie erst mit 30 Kills oder so.
Ab und zu vor.
Aber auch jetzt erst,
also am Anfang hat da nie jemand...
Irgendwas.
Ich geh mal mit rein.
Ich bin so ein krasser Noob in dem Game.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was das hier ist, was ich da habe.
Smoke oder...
Fahrzeug lasern oder
spotten oder...
Was kann ich hier überhaupt machen mit?
Also mit G kann ich glaube ich Proximity-Sensors machen.
Spotter.
Guck mal, ich hab den gespottet.
Schon wieder gebasht gleich.
Oh!
Äh.
Ich bin unsicher, was mich eigentlich
gerade gekillt hat.
War eine Brandgranate wahrscheinlich.
So, pass mal auf.
Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebensmüde.
Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebens... Ah ne, okay.
Sind wir tatsächlich... Ich wollte eigentlich sagen,
wir sind jetzt ein bisschen lebensmüde und versuchen,
rauf aufs Dach zu...
PP-Garen.
Mal gucken,
ob wir das hinkriegen.
Okay, der Erste ist dead.
Okay, nice.
Ich hoffe, da kommt jetzt nichts von hinten gleich.
Pass mal auf, Trick 17.
Fuck it!
Der Crumbling-Hook hat nicht so funktioniert,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Leider.
Wär ganz nicer Play
gewesen, oder?
Fuck.
In den Kopf geschossen!
Will ich...
Was sagen wir?
Ja.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Sehr schlau.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein! Shit!
Meine Munition war leer.
Ich hätte vier Stück jetzt einfach Hüft
sprayen können.
Shit, Alter.
Ah, na gut. Kann nicht alles klappen.
Kann nicht alles klappen.
Au, au, die sprengen uns die Luft gleich.
Ich muss mal kurz
verpissen. Hier rüber,
aufs Dach, rauf
und dann hoffen, dass da oben keiner rumkämpft
von denen. Was keiner macht
glücklicherweise. Okay, hier unten
ist alles down.
Okay, anscheinend alles weg.
Der Crumbling-Hook
sieht immer noch sehr klar... Ja.
War das PP-Ger-Aim,
oder hat es einfach nicht gehittet?
Oh, oh, von hinten. Wir werden gleich in die Luft
sprengen. Shit, ich muss raus.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit. Lass mich in Ruhe.
Nice.
Shit! Den hätte ich haben müssen.
Ich hätte wissen müssen, dass er jetzt... Oh, Twitch!
Leute!
Ich wurde gerade weggebasht.
Live on stream.
Höchstwahrscheinlich.
Wo ist der Dude?
Ey, Mann!
Kann ich mal... Okay, nice.
Habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich dieses Visier
absolut nicht mag?
Treff mir den
Dinger nix. So.
Shit.
Gut. Das Ding ist wirklich
nice, weil es einen eingebauten Schalldämpfer
hat, muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube, mit einem ordentlichen Visier
wäre das jetzt nochmal Doppel-Pog.
Und zu wenig Schuss.
Alter, sagt das mal.
Ey, what the fuck?
Was ist das für ein Visier, Mann?
Da ist auch keiner da, der mich
retzen kann.
Also ich glaube, ich muss da echt noch ein bisschen was anlocken.
Die Waffe ist geil mit eingebautem...
Hier, komm her.
Mit eingebautem
Schalldämpfer.
Ist schon sehr nice. Und die ist ziemlich
akkurat.
Wo muss man eigentlich hinschießen
bei diesem Ding? Auf die
Spitze? Oder
Zwischenspitze
und auf den Pfeil unten dran?
So leicht
unter die Spitze, oder?
Muss man den Gegner so
haben oder so haben?
Also müssen die in diesem Dreieck
drin sein oder auf der Spitze vom Dreieck?
Falls irgendjemand von euch das weiß.
Au!
Auf der Spitze?
Na, da hatte ich den eigentlich eben.
Fuck, ich hab zu wenig Leben. Ich muss warten,
bis der...
Wir switchen mal
kurz. Ich brauch ein bisschen was mit
mehr Schuss. Lasst mal kurz wieder
zurückgehen auf die M416.
Und jetzt volle Pulle
mit dem Jeep.
Oh, gib ihm.
Ja, fallen jetzt einfach hier
drüber. Und jetzt, jetzt probieren wir's.
Also hier unten ist... Wenn die mich
jetzt hier nicht rausholen...
Hier unten ist
extremely
hog.
Da denkt nie einer, dass man da ist.
Nie. Die checken's immer nicht, wenn man
hier ist. Guck hier,
der auch nicht.
Fuck, ich...
Voll reingerannt bin ich
in den Schuss.
Oh, der hätte mich retzen können. Nope.
Schnell, schnell, schnell. Rein, rein, rein.
Ach, wir haben's?
Nee, wir haben's nicht.
Dachte, wir haben's.
Oh, da drinnen ist...
Da drinnen ist voll.
Auf der Spitze, ja.
Die Runde läuft
gar nett.
No pass.
Aber so ist es halt manchmal.
Manchmal machst du nix.
Oh Gott, ey. Meine Güte,
wie schlecht.
Jetzt, Leute, nach
zwei Stunden setzt das
PPGAIM ein.
Ah, wir haben's. Okay. Glücklicherweise
haben's meine
Teammates diese Runde gerissen.
Oh, shit.
Weil die Runde geht
gar nix.
Guck mal hier. 11-13.
Keck. Ja.
Zu Boomer.
Geht einfach.
Sag mal, aber die Runde ist schon ziemlich krass, das ESL
Final, oder? Was ist denn da
hinter der Tür los? Sind die dead?
Ich glaub, die sind alle dead.
Nice.
Patrick wieder am Start. Ja, ich hab gar nicht
dran gedacht, dass ja bei euch eigentlich
heute gar kein Feiertag ist.
Medic, Oma.
Nice.
So, jetzt hier. Pass auf.
High Performance an der letzten Base.
What?
Leute, ich weiß doch nicht mal, von wo ich beschossen werde
gerade eigentlich.
Oh, das ist gar nix.
Alter, ich weiß nicht mal, von wo ich beschossen werde.
Okay.
Nice. Ein Gegner.
Oh, lege Hände.
Nice, jetzt drehen sie alle um.
Jetzt können wir sie von der Seite bashen.
Oh, ich hör was.
Die rennen jetzt alle hier, guck.
Ha! Bam!
Dafür ist die Pistol-Shotgun
tatsächlich ganz nice.
Einfach bei eurem Gegner reinspringen und
wegshotgunnen.
Wir haben's gleich.
Pass auf, vielleicht kriegen wir das. Nein, nein, du snipest mich nicht,
Kollege. Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, fuck.
Aber das ist gut. Bleibt alle auf der Street
sitzen. Wir haben gleich gewonnen. Pass auf.
Eins, zwei, bam, win.
Die haben halt mehr
an der Brücke gecampt und versucht uns abzufarmen,
anstatt auf ihre M-Comps zu achten.
Hm.
Hatte die Map eigentlich schon
einen Rework? Ich glaub schon.
Ich glaub, das war sogar
die erste oder die zweite Map, die einen Rework
bekommen hat.
Dann frage ich mich gerade, was genau war noch.
Ach ja, doch. Die haben die, die haben,
die haben, gut, auf Rush sieht man
von dem Rework, glaub ich, gar nicht so viel.
Auf Conquest haben sie viel gemacht.
Da hast du beispielsweise zwischen den, zwischen,
oder, oder auch auf, auf Breakthrough,
da hast du zwischen den Bases, hast du viel
mehr Cover jetzt mit, mit irgendwie
so kleinen Bergen und sowas.
Aber die Map ist, ja,
na ja,
ich find, die ist ziemlich top und flop,
die Map. Mal ist die richtig geil
und mal suckt die einfach nur.
Das Game lebt noch, ja,
na ja, mein, Games leben
bis die Server abgeschaltet werden.
Viele Spielen tun's nicht. Lass uns mal kurz rein,
kurz reingucken hier.
Steam Charts, BRF 2042.
Heißt übrigens gar nicht mehr Steam Charts.
Ach, heißt es wieder Steam Charts?
Hä? Bringst du jetzt durcheinander?
Ist das früher, heißt es jetzt
Steam Charts und früher hieß das anders?
Steam Stats hieß das früher, genau.
Und jetzt heißt es Steam Charts, so rum.
Ja, guck mal.
8.000 Leute, 8.000,
9.000 Leute normalerweise.
Und jetzt ist es halt wieder mal hochgegangen,
weil vorgestern,
nee, eigentlich gestern,
gestern, gestern Morgen,
gestern Mittag genau bei uns,
die neue Season gelaunched ist.
Man muss halt sagen,
wirklich viel ist es halt trotzdem nicht.
Ich denk mal, lass mal kurz gucken.
Steam Charts, BRF 4
und BRF 4 ist erst später gelaunched.
Ja.
Sogar so ein olles Game.
Und, äh,
BRF 1,
BRF 5?
Also,
BRF 1 und BRF 5 haben halt mehr
kontinuierliche Spieler
als 2042.
Das ist schon
ziemlich pp-iger.
Ach, nee.
Locked in. Wollte grad sagen,
wir könnten jetzt nochmal die Waffe switchen.
Ich brauch ja ein bisschen Unlocks dafür.
BRF 5 hat ein dickes
Cheater-Problem. Okay.
Und lass mich raten, DICE geht's am Arsch vorbei.
Na gut, was, ich mein,
mal ernsthaft,
da musst du bei sowas, musst du halt permanent
Energie reinstecken.
Ist ja immer so ein Wettlauf, Cheater und Player
und Cheater, Anti-Cheat
und sowas. Und die haben halt für ein
altes Game schlicht und ergreifend keinen Bock.
Auf der einen Seite kann ich sagen, ja,
aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht, ich versteh's,
aus spielerischer Sicht,
ist es halt scheiße, ne? Sag mal.
Und das ist eigentlich auch nix,
was ich jetzt irgendwie gut
heißen möchte.
In die Bobbes geschossen.
Nice.
Ich hatte schon,
ich hatte schon die blöde Ver-
Oh, fuck!
Diffuse-Henne.
Shit.
Ich wollte grad die Shotgun.
Aber es war close. Close, close, close.
Da merk ich immer, wenn ich ne Weile
keine Shooters gespielt habe,
dass ich in so Situationen, wo ich eigentlich
nur grob in die Richtung der Gegner
schießen müsste, aber ich krieg's halt von allen Seiten
ab, dass ich dann manchmal ein bisschen Panik kriege
und halt nix hätte.
Was eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert ist.
Die hier zu hitten
ist ja nicht schwer von der Entfernung.
Aber es ist halt...
Macht alles die Übung aus.
Au. Alles Übungssache.
Alles Übungssache.
Okay,
der ist aufm Dach.
Hätte ich den getroffen
mit der Shotgun. Das wär nice gewesen, oder?
Aber wir sind schon in ziemlichen ESL-Lobbys
gerade unterwegs.
Weiß auch nicht, was da immer los ist.
Fuck, ich woll durchs Fenster.
Ah, das geht wieder nicht.
So, ich muss mal
aufs Dach wieder hoch. Wie viel Schuss hat man eigentlich
mit der... Ach, man hat nur drei Schuss.
Ja gut, ist ja auch fair.
Ich mein, das ist ne Sidearm-
Shotgun. Stellt euch das mal mit acht
Schuss vor oder so. Das wär schon echt
viel zu OP. Eigentlich ganz gut
gebalanced. Welche GPU hast du?
Ich hab ne Zotac von Zotac.
Ne RTX 4090,
weil ich zu viel Geld ausgegeben
hab für mein Rechner.
Oh, fuck. Wär das geil gewesen, wär ich da
drauf gekommen. Wär ich da alle wegklatschen
können.
Und so haben wir wieder irgendeinen
Typ. Oh, oh, oh. Rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts.
In der Hoffnung, ich bin schneller als der.
Ja.
Nice.
So. Darf ich durchs Fenster?
Nein.
Nix da.
Ah, shit.
Da hat mich jetzt der Schalldämpfer
gekillt.
Komm, ihr braucht einen Hit auf den Dude.
Einen Hit, Leute.
Gibt's nicht. Kein Hit.
Hitge.
In Combat? Oh, oh, shit.
Okay, ich muss schnell, schnell
da rüber. Weil wir haben...
Komm mal, die haben noch neun Tickets.
Ey, please. Lass die das jetzt nicht
noch kriegen.
Fuck, das haben sie. Okay, wir müssen auf B.
Wir müssen auf B. Das kriegen wir nicht
mehr. Das kriegen wir nicht mehr. Hat keinen
Sinn. Besser ordentliche
Defense nochmal auf B.
Ja.
Ich meine, es sind doch noch sieben Tickets. Das sollten wir eigentlich ohne Probleme haben.
Aber ihr wisst, wie das ist.
Umso easier man was hat...
Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich seh nix.
Umso schwerer wird's.
Oh, zu viel. Viel zu viel. Viel zu viel.
Ich geh unten rein.
Ein Ticket noch.
Jawoll.
Geht.
Hast du gerade 300 FPS?
Ich hab sogar 300 FPS im Windowed Mode.
Man muss sagen, das geht in diesem Spiel
unglaublich schlecht zu recorden.
Im Windowed Mode. Also auf dem alten
Rechner konnte ich streamen
mit Game Capture Mode.
Allerdings nicht mit
Windowed Desktop Mode.
Allerdings jetzt, der Rechner ist fett genug.
Ja.
Cheat 95, so ist es.
Umso easier man denkt, dass es ist, umso
schlechter ist es.
Dann schränkt man sich nicht richtig an, gibt sich keine
Mühe beim Zielen, wackelt irgendwie rum.
Und wenn du denkst, jetzt muss man sich aber mal
anstrengen und so, dann klappt's meistens besser.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist Battlefield 2042
generell Battlefield
jetzt nicht mit anderen Games zu vergleichen.
Was so den...
Wie soll man sagen?
Die Lernkurve angeht, weil
es gibt eigentlich
keine richtige Lernkurve.
Man muss
zielen und schießen,
was man, wenn man so Games spielt,
ja, mehr oder weniger kann.
Und man muss sich ein paar Gadgets merken.
Ganz ehrlich, das Lernkurvigste
an Battlefield ist eigentlich
so den Fluss
von so einer Runde ungefähr
so drinnen haben.
Der Rest
ist easy AF
Collection.
Was ich aber gut finde,
immerhin haben die jetzt mittlerweile
so viele Maps drinnen, dass es nicht nach
einer Stunde spielen langweilig ist.
Wie viele Maps haben wir mittlerweile?
Zehn? Och nee.
Vielleicht sind wir Attacker Caspian Border.
Dann denke ich nochmal drüber nach, das zu spielen.
Aber nochmal Defender
Caspian Border hab ich keinen Bock.
Das stimmt. Jaja, ich rede jetzt nur von
Infanterie. Also Helis und
Jets lasse ich mir gefallen, wobei selbst
da die ganzen
Heli-Pros und Jet-Pros sagen, Battlefield
2042 ist für'n Arsch.
Was Fahrzeughandling angeht.
Vielleicht ist es mittlerweile besser.
Aber das war mehr oder weniger
die einhellige Meinung.
Mit oder ohne Portal-Karten?
Ohne. Also in der
normalen Rotation die Karte.
Achja, ich wollte mir das
Hier, guck mal. Guck mal Leute. Legacy-Feature.
Man kann jetzt Squads wechseln.
Komm, wir gehen
in das Morgendämmerer.
Leute, ich möchte
ein kleines Backend-14 laufen lassen.
Würdet ihr euch hier für ARM oder x86
Variante entscheiden? Kommt drauf an.
Brauchst du eher RAM oder
brauchst du eher CPU?
Wobei man sagen muss, die ARM-Dinger
sind...
Kannst du deine Last schön multithreaden?
Brauchst du mehr RAM als CPU?
Was ist so dein Anwendungswert?
In der Regel kann ich sagen, du bekommst
bei den ARM-Kisten
mehr RAM fürs
gleiche Geld.
Mehr CPU, kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Da kommt es ein bisschen drauf an,
wie so dein...
By the way, ich weiß absolut nicht, wie man mit den Dingern schießen muss.
Wir sind gleich dead hier übrigens.
Wie schießt man mit...
Wir bunnyhoppen einfach mal
rüber und hoffen, die hätten uns nicht.
What the fuck?
Okay.
By the way, ich stelle gerade fest, ich habe nichts ausgerüstet.
Ich muss gerade das nochmal...
Wo ist er? Ist er auf dem Dach?
Haha!
Lol!
Oh oh, der weiß, dass ich hier drinne bin. Der schießt gleich die Wand kaputt.
Nice.
Au!
Ich würde gerne mal reloaden.
Wenn das erlaubt ist.
So.
So zur Abwechslung mal.
Okay, reload.
Okay, jetzt können wir pushen, glaube ich.
Push the Reno.
Shit!
Zu wenig Leben. Hätte ich hier nicht auf die Shotgun switchen sollen?
Für Reloads brauchst du noch
einen Battle Pass.
Bring die mal nicht auf falsche Ideen.
Wie sind wir denn jetzt alle so schnell verreckt?
Okay, der ist gut.
Der Tut ist noch im Haus.
Ich camp auch mal eine Runde im Haus.
Oh oh oh, der weiß, dass ich da bin.
Oh shit!
Krieg ich den gerätst?
Okay.
Komm, Leute, Legehenne-Time!
Wo ist mein Smoke-Launcher?
Jawohl, da ist er.
Oh, schön!
Guck mal, synchrone Legehenne.
Ich glaube, wir müssen auf A bleiben.
Ich glaube, auf A geht mehr ab.
Vermutlich.
Oder auch nicht.
Die Fuske.
Keiner?
Okay, nice.
Ja, nice!
Kein Bock auf die Fuske.
Hatten sie da.
Oh, was ist denn das da?
Bin ich blind?
War da nicht gerade ein...
Ach, das war ein Panzer, den ich da gesehen habe.
Wenn es dann liegt, Grafik...
Wisst ihr was?
Change my mind!
Mir hat die Map
auch grafisch besser gefallen
in Battlefield 3.
Und das ist wie alt?
13 Jahre oder so?
Oh, oh, oh!
Panzer!
Das war zu viel Movement
für den MG-Typ im Panzer.
Richtige Bro-Moves.
Kommt man hier drüber?
Übrigens, war das Battlefield 1,
wo die Bauern sich drüber
ziehen konnten?
Glaube ja.
Oder Battlefield 5 auch noch.
Haben sich gedacht, in 2042, nope.
Das ist zu Legacy.
Das brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Wo sind die eigentlich alle gerade?
Oh, im MS sind die gerade.
Oh, das sind richtige
Objective-Players hier vorne.
Guck mal.
Medic, Recon, Spawnbeacon.
3D-Spotting ist schon ziemlich op.
Der Typ hat halt
absolut null Chance, da irgendwie
rauszukommen, wenn ich...
Sei da hinter einem Felsen zu sitzen.
Wie, der ist nicht down?
Und ich fliege jetzt in die Luft vom Panzer.
Ich hab Schiss.
Dahinten kommt was.
Okay, ich muss weg.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Achtung, pushen!
Shit.
Dachte, der lebt noch.
Ist der Dead-Guy auf dem Dach?
Wie komm ich denn hier wieder raus, Leute?
Komm ich hier raus?
What?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich hab Schiss.
Hier sind 30.000 Gegner gerade.
Charlie, Mike.
Krieg ich...
Krieg ich vielleicht ein bisschen Money?
Wobei, geht eigentlich.
Jetzt wird geruscht, Leute.
Hardcore geruscht.
Und am Wasser hängen geblieben wird.
Ich bin...
Das Verhältnis verlässt mich gerade.
Welche Seite ist das
mit dem Zaun und der Lagerhalle?
Links, oder?
Vor allem, wie weit links?
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ist zu lange her.
By more cases.
Geht richtig ab.
Ich verwundere mich, warum die Schüsse nicht ankommen.
Lege Henne.
Wo sind sie?
Haben wir noch ein paar Gegner?
Gegner?
Was?
Da ist noch einer.
Hinter mir ist ein Panzer.
Mein Hirn macht es gerade nicht mit.
Einer ist noch drin in der Base.
Ich bin mir unsicher,
wo ich bin.
Wenn ich Glück habe...
Jawohl.
Der Diffused, oder?
Saved.
Haben die in alten Battlefields auch schon angezeigt,
wenn einer gerade Diffused?
Das ist eigentlich total OP,
du kannst in der Deckung liegen bleiben
und campen,
und sobald du das Diffused-Symbol siehst,
gehst du aus der Deckung und schießt den um.
Das hast du nicht gesehen.
Du konntest das nur erahnen anhand dessen,
wenn der Counter gestoppt ist,
konntest du vermuten,
dass jemand gerade rangeht und Diffused.
Ja, du konntest das hören,
aber trotzdem, ich finde,
die Anzeige ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen...
Naja, ein bisschen zu viel, ist gut.
First Squad.
Pogu.
Es wäre halt cool,
wenn man jetzt in diesem Squad
weiterspielen könnte,
für die nächsten Runden.
Aber das gibt es halt dank...
Ich will nicht sagen SBMM,
es ist ja nur wirklich SBMM Lite,
aber es ist im Prinzip sowas, ja?
Gibt es das halt nicht mehr.
Wir müssten die jetzt quasi
Inviten und...
Guck mal, Holo.
Müsste jetzt quasi Inviten
neue Formen und suchen und...
Übrigens,
morgen
oder am Samstag
werden wir tatsächlich
mal einen Progress Stream wieder machen.
Javascript Frontend Kram.
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Ich war die letzten Zeit auch so...
Weiß ich nicht, irgendwie so kaputt auch
und musste mir so viel Neues auf der Arbeit angucken
und sowas, da hatte ich keinen Bock.
Aber ich habe heute Morgen ein Video gesehen,
ein UI Framework
eine UI Library fürs Weltkit.
Und das
müssen wir uns mal angucken, morgen oder am Samstag.
Let's go Battlefield.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen, man könnte das Spiel demnächst mal
releasen.
Guter Playtest ist es gerade.
Also Leute, was sagt ihr denn?
Für eine Beta läuft es ganz gut, oder?
Exposure.
Die haben wirklich Quotes unten.
So als hätte das Spiel eine Kampagne.
Restreams
Summer Game Fest heute.
Von welchem Hersteller ist das?
Ach nee, das ist so eine Veranstaltung.
EA? Was gibt es denn da?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich gucke mir nur
Zusammenfassungen an. Wir müssen übrigens noch
die Zusammenfassung anschauen, was jetzt eigentlich
bei der letzten...
Was bei Apple rausgekommen ist.
Das wollte ich mir eigentlich gestern mit euch schon angucken,
hatte aber doch keinen Bock mehr einzuloggen.
Okay, Exposure Defense wieder.
Na gut. Was kommt denn heute dran?
Wer präsentiert
dann Summer Fest irgendwas?
Was so Konferenzen angeht
und sowas, seitdem ich aus Prinzip
nicht mehr auf solche
Events fahre,
habe ich da auch gar keinen...
Wir sollten rüber zu A. Hier sind viel zu viele
auf B.
Siehste?
Na, war schon wieder blöd. Hätte ich mal gemacht, was ich
gesagt habe und wäre nicht einfach auf A gerannt.
Nice. Oh, der Lukas.
Pogu Lukas.
Wieder am Start.
Kann ich zu denen ins Squad?
Äh, gibt's nicht.
Okay, wir probieren mal was aus. Wir probieren mal
PPGAIM
Nummer 75 heute.
In so Situationen
denke ich mir dann immer, okay,
müsstest du halt mal ein bisschen mehr
spielen wieder. Aber
dann denke ich mir,
ne, eigentlich so, du brauchst halt
ein Game, was du spielen kannst.
Ich habe übrigens Gerüchte gehört, wo wir
jetzt hier gerade bei Battlefield sind, ne.
Ich habe Gerüchte
gehört, dass 2024
Battlefield 6 kommen soll.
Irgendwo auf Twitter oder so
habe ich das gelesen.
Mein Twitter und so,
ne, Twitter.
Au!
Okay, B können wir halten.
Ich fände es aber auch nicht
schlecht, wenn wir die Base losen, dass wir mal ein bisschen
mehr von der Map sehen. Lass mich rein,
please.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
Ich, ich, ich,
oh shit.
Ich trau mich hier gerade nicht.
Okay, wenn ich Glück hab.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh nein!
Ich bin komplett gerade in die
Granaten gerannt.
Okay, wir müssen irgendwie aufs Dach.
Dach, Dachge.
Dachge OP.
Ja, nice.
Dachhut gewinnt einfach.
Ja, ja, ja, ist gut, ich hab dich.
Nice.
Oh, jetzt haben sie
ihr Sniper-Dudes. Aber wie das
so immer ist in Rush,
au, wow, wow, je mehr Snipers,
umso wahrscheinlicher der Lose.
Wow!
Instant weggedrückt.
Die haben das ja auch gepatcht.
Also die haben ja diese Season, haben die ja nur
und das habe ich auch gleich, als ich das gesehen habe,
dachte ich mir, okay, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst.
Sie haben nur die Sturmgewehre angepasst.
Sonst...
Sonst nichts.
Witzigerweise. Sehr pp-gar.
Okay, wir müssen...
Oh shit, die haben Legehenne
gemacht. Okay, Legehenne!
Ich probier's, ich probier's.
Please, Prager, Prager, Prager, Prager,
Prager. Nice.
Prager, Prager
successful.
Successfully prayed.
Alter, wo stellst'n die denn alle?
Oh nee, die haben wieder Legehenne gemacht.
Komm, wir haben's.
In the bobbas.
Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir die von oben.
Nichts zu sehen,
nichts zu sehen.
Oh, die sterben ziemlich. Da muss ich, glaube ich,
unten rein. War klar,
dass er hier ist. Ich mein, irgendwo muss der ja hin sein.
Okay, okay, defuse skill,
defuse skill.
Alter, das ist... Das ist wieder krass, ey.
ESL Finals, man.
Prager, Prager, Prager, Prager. Nein!
Nein!
Und meine Teammates haben Schiss, das zu defusen.
Defuse skill, Leute.
Defuse skill.
Oh!
Oh! ESL Finals,
Leute.
Übelst anstrengend
die letzten zwei Minuten.
Was? Eigentlich wäre das...
Cheat95 meint,
eigentlich wäre das ein witziger Move
von EA, wenn das nächste Battlefield
erst 2042 rauskommt.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Wollte gerade sagen,
dafür sind die viel zu geil auf unser Geld.
Titanfall 3,
das wäre echt geil, ja.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, gestorben zugunsten von Apex.
SgtSilver, du hast anscheinend
keinen Feiertag heute, oder?
Sah so aus, ja.
Was ist denn der Modus, in dem man am meisten
Punkte für den Battle Pass macht?
Ich würde gern mal
die KegW46 ausprobieren,
aber da braucht man Battle Pass Level
26, man.
Was ist denn Holosight
für eine Shotgun-Pistole?
Was ist denn mit euch verkehrt?
Conquest? Oh ne, Conquest mag ich nicht.
Dann spiele ich...
Dann gehe ich auf irgendeinen Boost-Server in Portal
lieber. Dabei sind
Apex und Titanfall nicht wirklich vergleichbar.
Naja, das sind aber die gleichen Leute, die das
entwickeln. Allein schon deswegen ist zugunsten
Apex Titanfall 3 erstmal gestorben.
Es sei denn, die wollen halt ein neues Team
gründen für Titanfall 3. Oder Leute von Apex
abziehen dafür, aber das glaube ich nicht, dass sie das
machen werden. Hast du Battle Pass
gekauft? Ne.
Ich würde im Leben kein Battle Pass kaufen.
Präge.
Kein Geld.
Da gibt's
kein Geld von mir für das Game mehr.
Oder kann man sich irgendwie Battle Pass
Boost mit diesen 500 Battlefield Points
kaufen, weil die brauche ich eh nicht.
Was macht man eigentlich mit diesen komischen...
Äh, ist zu spät. Erika
Harbour
in Chile. Oder wie die Amis sagen
Chili.
Ähm.
Erika Harbour funktioniert auch nur sehr begrenzt
in Battlefield 2042.
Aber es freut mich immer
die Oldschool Maps zu sehen.
Fight smart and stay alive.
That's how it works out sometime.
Ne, was hat Angel gesagt immer?
That's how it works
sometime. Irgendwie sowas.
Angel does it again.
Valparaiso ist auf Conquest richtig gut.
Ja, das ist auch eine gute Conquest Map. Gute Rush und
gute Conquest Map.
Frage mich, ist Valparaiso hier überhaupt
im Rush drinne? In der normalen
Rotation?
Ja?
Hehehe.
Ich springe hier mal ab.
Äh.
Gott.
Schauen wir mal, was hier so kommt. Ein
Panzer.
Oh Gott, wie
OP grad er.
Ey, ich hab nur einen gekillt. Ich hatte so
eine geile Position, alter.
So eine Pog-Position.
Und
hab's verkackt. Oh nice, noch
einer. GG.
Du solltest besser nicht nachladen, ne?
Okay, nice. Dankeschön.
Der hat ernsthaft ne Claymore dahinter
gestellt, ne?
Oh, oh, der Tank. Oh, der
Panzer. Panzer, gehst du
weg? Panzer, Panzer, verpiss dich.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wisst ihr, es wär
mega, wenn die einfach nur
komplett, komplett braindead
in die
normale Rotation noch die
Rush Maps von Battlefield 3 reinhauen würden.
Sowas
wie Damavent Peak zum Beispiel oder
meinetwegen auch Firestorm oder
Grand Bazaar und sowas.
Dann hätten wir wenigstens ein paar gescheite Maps einfach
hier.
Ey, das kannst du vergessen, Kollege.
Da hast du dir...
Das hast dir so gedacht, ne? Das hast dir so
gedacht. Okay, easy.
Guck mal, schon 30 Tickets weg, wir haben gleich gewonnen.
Gleich.
In Anführungszeichen.
Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo
die meisten liefen immer bei Eureka Harbor.
Wenn die ersten zwei
Attacks nicht geklappt haben und sie das neu
aufbauen, müssen die meisten Rage quitten jetzt.
Oder versuchen
sinnlose... Wir rushen
mit dem Buggy rein
und versuchen alles zu killen.
Oh, ich
seh den nicht. Wo ist der Dude?
Okay, ich hab den Shit.
Sag mal!
So.
Topski, los, man! Hör mal auf, so
rumzuflitzen. Anzeige.
Direkt.
Attacker of Eureka Harbor ist so shit, sagt der
Chat. In
2042 geb ich dir recht,
aber in Battlefield...
Bad Company 2
konntest du
A immer einnehmen,
indem du die Pfeiler von dem
Gebäude mit dem Panzer kaputt geschossen hast
und dann konntest du dich auf B konzentrieren.
Es war auch schon kacke, ja.
Also ziemlich imbalanced.
Aber es ging noch.
Ich hab nichts
gegen den Panzer.
Ich klau den jetzt, den Panzer.
Oh ne, shit.
Da kommen sie einfach zu dritt rein.
Da jumpen sie.
Okay, das... Nice! Nice!
Die sehen den nicht! Die sehen den nicht!
Oh ne, die sehen auch an B! Fuck!
Was ist da los? Hört mal auf!
Ah, okay.
Die sind ja frech.
Die legen einfach beides.
So.
Das ist aber nicht nett.
Ist kein Daumen hoch.
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, YOLO!
YOLO! YOLO!
Oh, hier ist ja alles
kaputt schon.
Oh, oh, da drüben.
Da drüben rusht was.
Wo sind sie?
Dead, oder?
Vermutlich. Vermutlich dead.
Bleiben wir mal hier stehen.
Also meistens
haben die Attacker spätestens jetzt keinen Bock mehr.
Es ist vermutlich...
Ja, guck mal, die stehen schon nur noch mit den Tanks in der Base.
Easy. Und snipen.
Snipen und Tanks in der Base stehen.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Da weißt du, dass du gewonnen hast.
Soundrifles sind echt komisch jetzt.
Aber da weißt du, dass du eigentlich gewonnen hast.
Oder? Oder? Oder?
Kann ich die wiederbeleben?
Nein! Ich will nicht deine hässliche Waffe haben.
Wow, die Schneiders!
Oh, ne.
Die legen! Ich geh doch mal rüber.
Ich habe meine...
Ich traue meinem Team nicht, dass sie das hinbekommen.
Ich...
Ich defende einfach A, bis es vorbei ist.
Zwei Tickets noch.
Das sollten wir eigentlich locker haben.
Hold tight.
Wir holen tight, Leute.
Ich hoffe, ihr holdet auch tight.
Nice win.
Ja, Erika Haber funktioniert nicht so richtig gut
in 2043.
Also in BC2 war es schon schwierig.
Wobei...
Ich überlege gerade, was ist meine Lieblings-BC2-Map
gewesen?
Weil Paraise ist
auf jeden Fall vorne mit dabei.
Finde ich mega nice.
Aber Port Walders.
Doch, die Schneemap. Erinnert sich noch einer dran
mit der Pipeline an der Seite?
Port Walders war, glaube ich, meine Lieblings-Rush-Map
in Bad Company 2.
Wobei die eigentlich alle mehr oder weniger geil waren.
Die Bad Company 1-Maps
waren auch ziemlich nice.
Die Battlefield 3-Rush-Maps waren auch gut.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
die BC1- und BC2-Maps waren halt
noch geschliffener
für Rush, aber
BF3 ging auch, klar, für Rush.
BF4 waren die Rush-Maps schon nicht mehr gut.
Danach gab es, glaube ich, keinen Rush mehr.
Doch, Battlefield 1 hatte noch Rush,
aber die Maps haben richtig gesackt.
Haben wir nicht eben schon mal bei 10?
Moin, Adi.
So, wie funsten das jetzt mit dem Battle Pass?
Buy Premium?
Nee, nee, bestimmt nicht.
Kann ich mit... Was kann ich denn mit...
Alter.
Money Fest, nice. Die hatten wir heute noch nicht.
Das ist auch so eine Hit-
Top-Top- und Flop-Map in Rush.
Kann
richtig geil sein, kann aber auch
einfach nur sacken.
Und wir nehmen mal anstatt der Messer tatsächlich wieder Granaten mit.
Was kann man denn für eine Auswahl?
Smoke Launcher, Armor Plate
brauchen wir nicht.
C5. Nee, wir lassen den Smoke Launcher.
Smoke ist geil. Und Attacker.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, am Anfang, als Rush
neu war, in 2042,
dass man
nach einer Runde nicht die Seite
geswitched hat? Oder die Seiten
immer gleich geblieben sind? Also, warst du
einmal Attacker, warst du immer Attacker und so was?
So richtig Banane
alles. Wo ich mir so denke,
probiert ihr das im Vorfeld nicht aus,
bevor ihr das ins Game packt?
Und die Antwort ist, nö.
Sie probieren es nicht aus.
Anders kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Die machen das,
Chat, ich glaube, DICE
hat meinen Stream consulted,
wenn es um Softwareentwicklung geht.
Die haben sich einfach gedacht, wenn man
keine Fehler macht,
wow, wenn man keine Fehler macht, dann braucht man
auch keine Tests.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie ganz
viele Fehler gemacht haben und nicht getestet.
So geht das nicht.
Also, das geht nur,
wenn du halt auch immer perfekt
programmierst. Easy.
So wie wir im Stream immer.
Obviously.
Ich würde gerne aufs Ding oben drauf.
Jawohl.
Es ist immer den,
den man nicht sieht. Immer
den, den man nicht sieht.
Aufschwing dein Pommes bisschen vor.
Ich glaube,
ich habe keine Ahnung.
Bewege ein, setzt wieder ein.
Oh, shit.
Ich renne einfach mal weiter.
Ich flank die.
Ich muss noch was anderes spielen.
Chat, Waffenvorschläge?
Irgendwas anderes.
Ich habe die zu lange gespielt heute.
Kein Bock mehr.
Komm, wir spielen die neue.
Nee, keine Single-Schuss-Craftinger.
Und auch kein Schneiberzeug.
Wir spielen die angeblich
OP-Waffe mal ein bisschen frei.
Ich habe bis jetzt noch nicht,
die OP ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig erkannt.
Was aber auch an meinem Visier
und dem 20-Schuss-Magazin
wahrscheinlich liegt.
Ich trau mich da grad nicht so richtig lang.
Ich trau mich hier grad
nicht so richtig hin.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall mal hier oben rauf.
Wo ist er? Wo ist er?
Wo ist der Dude?
Hier.
Aber weit können die ja nicht sein.
Juhu.
Erwischt.
Oh, angestelft
von der Seite hat er sich.
Nächste Runde Botten ist die Waffe frei.
Ich habe die schon unlockt mit Botten.
Ich will euch...
Oh, was kommt denn da von hinten?
Ich will euch nicht noch eine Runde Bots zumuten.
Boah.
ESL-Skills
werden rausgeholt hier.
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt,
wie viel besser das wieder geht,
wenn man das Game einfach mal
zwei Stunden gespielt hat.
Das macht halt schon was aus.
Sechs Monate kein Battlefield.
Kann der mal sterben?
Nice.
Also als kleinen Tipp, Leute, falls ihr auch mal irgendwie
mit der neuen Season spielen wollt.
Wenn ihr Assault Rifles spielt...
Wenn ihr Assault Rifles spielt,
ihr müsst die
Assault Rifles tappen.
Du triffst über Range
nichts mehr, wenn du
schießt. Also wenn du ohne zu
tappen schießt.
Wo ist der Unterschied zwischen Rush und Durchbruch?
Rush gibt's
128 Spieler.
Durchbruch gibt's 128 Spieler, Rush nicht.
Die
Breakthrough-Geschichten sind...
Wir stehen sinnlos rum
und Rush ist halt liegen vor einer Bombe.
Guck mal, wie du nichts triffst,
wenn du Dauerfeuer machst.
Der ist gar nicht mehr da.
Und Rush ist halt einfach ein geiler Modus
und Breakthrough nicht.
Warum spielst du das Game noch?
Weil ich's gekauft hab.
Und es eine neue Season gibt.
Okay, jetzt haben wir
einen nice Flank.
Alter, wie man mit diesen scheiß Waffen nichts mehr hittet.
Und jetzt weiß er, dass ich da bin.
Okay, der wirft auf jeden Fall
jetzt eine Granate hoch, da muss ich weg.
Hogger's Flank.
Nichts mehr da. Wo sind sie denn?
Okay, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Die wissen, dass ich da bin.
Was zum Teufel ist dieses Ding?
Das hat mich
schon total aufge... Ist das der Airburst?
Ist das dieses Airburst-Ding?
Das hat mich schon
so oft gekillt heute.
Ist das der Airburst?
Campbell?
SPH Explosive?
Ah, wir haben's, nice.
Gigi?
Ist er ein Granatwerfer?
Ist das dieser Airburst? Ah, nee, das ist nicht
der exclusive Airburst
für den vorletzten Specialist.
Was anderes.
Ah, dead.
Ja, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was das für einer ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist der auch gar nicht so geil.
Ich denk nur, dass das Ding
was taugt, weil's mich schon fünfmal gekillt hat.
Wenn man's dann
selbst spielt, ist es meistens eh nicht so geil.
Nice, wir sind schon durch.
Shit.
Okay, das war blöd, hier vorzuraschen.
Hätte ich eigentlich denken können. Vielleicht krieg ich ja ein Revive.
Wobei es... Ja, ja, ja, mach den
dead, mach den dead. Und jetzt, und jetzt
Revive, gell?
Excellent. Oh, shit, von der
Seite, von... Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Schon wieder das Ding.
Ist das
sowas wie die Explosivarmbrust
aus Black Ops 1?
Mit so nem sticky Ding?
Okay, ich seh keine
Enemies. Kannste ja mal
komplett knicken hier.
Wo müssen wir überhaupt hin? Ah, zu...
Ah.
Sind nicht viele da, ne?
Geh mal aufs Dach.
Dach, gell? Okay.
Kein Dachstelz.
Blöd zu treffen.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie ich da anders hitten soll.
Aber gut. Der ja auch nicht.
Nice, PP Guard.
Lass mich bloß in Ruhe hier.
Aber wir sollten's haben.
Ich denke, ich denke, wir haben's.
Ja, nice.
Wie? Hä?
Das ist jetzt auch die letzte Base?
Mein...
Man musste doch da sonst immer auf den
Berg oben drauf.
Haben die einfach die letzten Bases von
Rush gestrichen auf manchen Maps?
Die letzte Base war doch immer
in dieser Station
oben auf dem Berg.
Oder bringe ich jetzt Rush und Breakthrough
durcheinander?
Nee.
Reworked. Ich fand das eigentlich...
Ich fand das eigentlich besser,
als es
noch auf
den Berg oben ging.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich so ein großer Fan
von diesem Reworked bin.
Das ist ein bisschen kurz, vier Bases.
Continue.
So, was kann man denn jetzt mit
diesem komischen...
Was macht man mit diesen Battlefield Points?
Ich bin da richtig
kacknubig.
Wie macht man da was? Battle Pass? Store?
Ah ja, im Store kann man sich so Dinger kaufen.
Gibt's da auch.
Upgrade to Premium
Battle Pass.
Nope.
Machen wir nicht.
Garantiert
No Pass.
Und wie bekommt man diese Battlefield Points?
Wahrscheinlich nicht durch Spielen, sondern nur durch...
Reinkaschen.
Kaufe ich nicht.
Mache ich nicht.
Können sie komplett knicken.
Ich hab kein weiteres Geld mehr
für das Game aus.
Ja, bist du. Aber ich auch.
Scharf. So, jetzt mal andere Waffe
hier. Jetzt...
Mal das Teil. Mal ein bisschen
anlocken.
Attacker, jawoll.
Wir haben halt dafür nur das
kack Visier und nur
richtige...
Das kack Magazin und das kack Visier
haben wir dafür.
Also,
es gibt sogar noch Server für Bad Company 2.
So.
Eins, zwei Aktive abends.
Und...
Battlefield 3 gibt's
eigentlich ein, das ist 24
7 Damavent Peak.
Den gibt es.
Find ich persönlich jetzt aber nicht so geil.
Und wenn du Glück hast, am Wochenende mal so 4, 5 Server
insgesamt. Sag mal, das ist auch neu, oder?
Ja, das ist auch komplett
reworked.
Shit.
Also, das letzte Mal,
als ich Battlefield 3 gespielt hab, war eigentlich
dieser 24 7 Damavent Peak
Server immer besetzt.
Wobei ich den halt nicht gut fand.
Aber immerhin. Ich mein, man konnte zumindest
spielen, ne? War nicht normalerweise,
dass da drüben...
Hm.
Ja, Bad Company 3 wird's nicht geben.
Weil DICE ja gesagt hat, oh nein,
wir haben vergessen, wie Bad Company überhaupt
funktioniert hat. Wir verstehen unser eigenes
Game nicht mehr. Deswegen können wir
keinen dritten Teil machen.
Wo ich mir halt überlege,
so, naja...
Die Waffe suckt mit so wenig
Schuss. Wo ich mir halt denke,
okay, dann spielt halt vielleicht
mal euer eigenes Game ein paar Runde
und guckt euch an,
was gut ist. Aber ich glaube, im Jahr
2023 ist es halt für
Spieleentwickler von AAA-Titeln
nicht mehr, äh...
Gehört nicht mehr zur agilen
Arbeitsmethode dabei, seine eigenen...
Seine eigenen Krempel zu spielen.
Die sind zu...
Die sind zu agil und mit
Shira-Tickets und Daily Scrum beschäftigt, anstatt
ihr eigenes Game zu spielen.
Rekt.
Was ist eigentlich auf die Dächer, ohne bei Kate
zu sein? Ne.
Oh, da war noch mehr.
Ich würde gerne
hoch aufs Dach. Dankeschön. Voll gut.
Oh, da war noch mehr. Ich hab's
genau gesehen. Hier.
Die Waffe hat viel zu kleines
Magazin.
Okay, ich weiß nicht von wo, aber...
Von wo?
Ach, da!
Okay, PP-Guard.
Kommst du her?
Ach, der ist dead. Lul.
War da einer?
Leute, war da einer?
Sag mal,
bin ich...
War da nicht einer gerade?
Dead?
An die Map muss ich mich noch gewöhnen, die ist auch komplett
neu für mich. Ich hab den Rework nicht gespielt.
Wann kam denn der Rework? Kam der Season 4?
Leute, weil Season 4 konnte ich nicht
spielen. In Season 4 ist mein Spiel nicht gestartet.
Season 4 konnte ich nicht spielen.
Du bist der Einzige in meinem Twitch, der nicht Diablo zockt.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht mal gekauft.
Für das, dass ich mein...
meine halbe Jugend in Diablo 2
gesteckt hab, ist das
schon wenig.
Aber ich war sehr enttäuscht von Diablo 3
und Blizzard hat mich auch die letzten Jahre
über immer abgefuckt.
Deswegen weiß ich immer noch nicht,
ob ich's kaufen soll. Also ich glaube, ich werd' das so
machen. Ich kauf' mir Diablo
4.
Ich kauf' mir Diablo 4, wenn
ich mir ein Review angeguckt hab oder
wenn ich zufälligerweise ein Review finde von
irgendwelchen YouTubern, Streamern,
sonst wie, von denen ich weiß, dass die...
ja, keine Ahnung,
wissen, wovon sie reden, was
Action-RPGs angeht. Und wenn
die sagen, das hat Langzeit-Motivation,
dann hol' ich's vielleicht noch.
Äh, what?
What? Was ist mit
meinem Enterhaken los?
Ist der irgendwie broken?
Path of Exile größer Diablo?
Ja. Ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube, dass das nach wie vor gilt.
Und auch mit
Diablo 4. Immer noch.
Diablo 4 ist wahrscheinlich
das casual-freundlichere
Game. Fuck it,
Alter. Ich kann nicht reden und spielen.
Ähm, Diablo 4
ist wahrscheinlich das casual-freundliche
Game, weil man muss ehrlich sagen, Path of Exile
ist halt echt
wir, wenn man da neu einste...
Schön, jetzt sind wir einander
vorbeigesprungen.
Ach, das ist da unten.
Ah, ich dachte, man kann die Typen auch rausschießen.
Nee, nee,
mich kriegst du nicht, Heli-Stelzer.
Das kannst du vergessen.
So, darf man noch
in die Mitte hoch?
Ach, da ist schon alles drauf
mit... da ist schon alles
drauf voll mit Schneiber-Dudes.
Oh, ich bin zu tief.
Wo geh ich denn hin?
Was mach ich jetzt? Kann man hier aufmachen?
Hier ist alles dicht.
Win!
Nice. Zwar nicht so viel krass gerissen,
die Runde, aber easy win, easy life.
Alles gut.
Hm.
Du spielst gerade ESF 6.
Was ist es? Street Fighter?
Wahrscheinlich Street Fighter.
Ja.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die in Diablo
einen langen
Content-Plan haben.
Weil ich hab gehört,
dass man in der Kampagne von Diablo 4
noch nicht mal
gegen Diablo fightet.
Ich kenn die Kampagne nicht, deswegen kann ich euch auch nicht spoilern.
Ich kann euch nur das, was ich gelesen hab.
Und
so wie ich das verstanden habe,
ist in Diablo 4 gar keiner der großen Bosse,
die man kennt, dabei.
Die haben ganz viel Expansion-Möglichkeit.
Die können einen
Mephisto-DLC machen, einen Diablo-DLC,
einen Baal-DLC, einen
hab ich auf jeden Fall vergessen,
DLC.
Also die könnten schon coole Sachen...
Ah, guck mal, wir haben einen neuen Suppressor.
Ist der besser als der andere?
Sekunde.
Collection.
Oh!
Walparaiso!
Pogu!
Endlich!
Pass auf, und jetzt sack die Runde richtig!
Scheiß Magazin haben wir noch nicht.
Und wir sind auch
Attacker. Nice.
Let's go!
Also ich glaub, die haben einen sehr langfristigen Content-Plan
für Diablo 4. Also es könnte schon cool sein,
wenn man immer mal wieder so
keine Ahnung,
so für einen Monat ab und zu
immer mal wieder grinden will.
Also ein bisschen so, wie das bei Diablo 3
es hießen zwar. Nur, dass ich halt
auf Diablo 3 keinen wirklich Bock hatte.
So, was ist denn
besser? Weapon Accuracy,
Effective Range.
Der kritisiert das schon ganz gut so.
So, okay, Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz in Bad Company 2
Mindset umschalten.
Rechte Seite am Wasser ist doch das
beste immer gewesen.
Bilde ich mir ein.
Rechte Seite am Wasser war immer Pog.
Extrem...
Es sei denn, hier passiert halt so was,
dass einer mitkriegt, dass du rechte Seite am Wasser rennst.
Dann spawnen wir
doch halt mal vorne rein.
Aber wir müssen irgendwie
rüberflanken, sonst ist das
frontal sucked halt. Okay.
Alter, der Dude
ist immer noch da!
Ja, die Preise im Diablo-Shop hab ich
auch nicht so genau gecheckt, warum ich irgendwie...
Ups, was war denn das?
Warum ich irgendwie
27 Euro oder so ausgeben
soll für einen komischen Pferdeskin
oder so.
Jetzt ist ja mal gut, Mann!
Please!
Darf ich mal irgendwas killen?
Ne.
Darf ich nicht. Und jetzt ist die Attack
auch durch. Also die
kriegen die diffused.
Was? Echt? Dachte eigentlich.
Okay.
Nice.
Starke Runde, ja.
Da sieht man die
15 Jahre Battlefield-
Erfahrung eindeutig.
Absolutes Peak-Battlefield
hier. Okay,
jetzt ist er... Ich hab grad gedacht,
er sitzt wieder da.
Okay, nice.
Das Off-Range ist ziemlicher Suck.
Das sollten wir haben.
Die kommen nicht hierhin mehr.
Das sei denn, die pushen richtig hart
durch, aber...
Hä? Wo seid ihr denn?
Nice! Ein Kill, Leute!
Easy win! Jetzt die Runde ist gerettet.
Ja, jetzt geht's
los. Ja, jetzt haben
wir sie.
Was war denn das?
Ach, man kann ja sogar durchs Fenster durch.
What do you think
about the game? I think
you can... You should make
a public playtest right now and maybe you can
release it end of the year.
Shit. Wenn man mal aimen könnte.
In the ass!
Gachi!
Oh!
Ja, gleich New...
Okay, ich check's manchmal nicht, warum das
nicht hittet. 17!
Was ist mit dem Typ los? Das ist unser Heli-Typ,
oder? Ne, das ist der Drohnen-Typ.
Der mit 17 ist der Drohnen-Typ. Also Drohnen
auf der Map in 2042. Keine Ahnung
warum das überhaupt ein Ding ist.
Die Dinger fand ich in Bad Company 2
schon ziemlich pp-ga.
Kennt ihr noch die Typen, die immer
in der Base gecampt sind, bis die
Drohne respawned ist, die die ganze Runde nix
gemacht haben im BC2 außer Drohne zu campen?
Einfach
24-7 Drohne campen.
Oh, das hier ist schutzsicher.
Yep,
jeder kennt die noch.
Und die Büsche,
die Wände sind auch äußerst
kugelsicher hier.
Fuck! Ich dachte, er steht auf!
Shit.
Der Nicky dachte, dass er liegen bleibt. Na gut.
Kann ja alles klappen.
Nix.
Wow, au, au, au, au.
Okay, schwimm,
schwimm, Stelz, schwimm.
Übrigens in BC2 konnte man im Wasser
schießen. Nur mal
angemerkt, glaub ich.
Komplett kugelsicheres Holz.
Wir brauchen mehr
Schuss.
Mehr Schuss.
Okay, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wo er
hin ist. Wo ist der Typ
hin gerade? Achtung.
Geht noch das Außenrum
laufen hier?
Geht noch. So
halbwegs geht das Außenrum
laufen noch. Zwar
nicht so schön wie in BC2, aber
ähnlich.
Oh, was ist denn da unter mir?
Nix.
Da kommt was.
Gucken wir mal, wo die jetzt langkommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die hier spawnen.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Wo haben wir denn hier Gegner?
Da. Oh, ich hoffe,
die sehen mich nicht.
Alter, das ist viel zu wenig Schuss.
Zum Glück sehen die mich
hier oben nicht, lol.
Ey, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich die noch hitten muss.
Beziehungsweise weiß ich nicht, wo ich auf dem
wo ich auf dem ACOG
Yep, ACOG hinzielen muss.
Schade war's aufs Battlefield
geworden.
Man könnte sagen,
schade
war's
aus
dem Default Gaming die letzten Jahre
über geworden ist.
Man muss ja schon froh sein,
dass Diablo 4 bei einem Vollpreisspiel
Alter, ist aber gut, man.
Dass Diablo 4 bei einem Vollpreisspiel
keine
Pay2Win Elemente enthält.
Naja, vielleicht ein bisschen.
Keine Pay2Win Elemente enthält.
Oder irgendwelche anderen Must-Have Sachen.
Wo dann gesagt wird,
ja ne, ihr könnt es doch auch
alles freispielen.
Jetzt regt euch mal nicht so auf, ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Alles freispielbar.
Man braucht halt 5000 Stunden,
aber es ist alles freispielbar.
Ist doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich brauch unbedingt das 30-Schuss-Magazin.
Hab ich das vielleicht schon?
Ne.
Da krieg ich Anfälle mit der Waffe, wenn ich das...
Nach der Runde haben, denke ich mal.
Und das bessere Visier.
Ja, ich weiß es immer nicht.
Muss ich die Gegner auf der Spitze haben?
Oder muss ich die leicht
unter der Spitze haben?
Ich hab bis heute ACOG-Visiere noch nicht kapiert.
Yep, yep, ACOG.
Ok, wir rushen einfach
mittendurch jetzt, easy.
Ok, jetzt hier durch die
Schlucht.
Ok, ist recht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yep, yep.
Oh, ich hab Schiss hier rauszugehen, Leute.
Den krieg ich nicht.
Fuck it.
Oh.
Ich brauch meinen Smoke-Granatwerfer.
Ach, jetzt ist hier...
Jetzt ist hier nix mehr.
Wow.
Ich kann ihn nicht holen.
Vielleicht jetzt?
Achtung, Achtung, Spritz in den Arsch, jawoll.
Reingeschoben.
Diffuse-Gear.
Das erlauben die sich das hier einfach zu diffusen, Mensch.
Ich hab da so ein bisschen
Schiss gerade,
hier hinter zu laufen.
Guck mal, wie viel hier ist, ich muss hier lang.
Ja, ja, ja, easy, easy.
Aber der lebt noch.
Mit ner Shotgun, Mann.
Alter, ich krieg...
Was? Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck, wär meine Shotgun ready gewesen.
Wär mal
meine Shotgun ready gewesen, Alter.
Die hätten auf den Sack gekriegt.
Okay, auf dem Dach sind viele.
Aufpassen.
Da hinten ist irgendein
Schneiber-Typ.
Fuck it, Mann.
Ich hab zu wenig Schuss in dieser Waffe.
Scoreboard-Legacy-Feature.
Nice, Rats.
Ich hätt einfach weiterschießen sollen,
anstatt auf die Pistole zu switchen.
Okay, wenn ich Glück habe...
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ganz schlechte Idee.
PPGAIM, meine Schuld.
Kann ja nix für.
Auch, kann das Game auch nix für.
Das große
Mech, ja, ja, ich gucke, ich gucke.
Ne, wie viel brauch ich denn
da noch für? Noch 6 Kills, okay.
Fuck.
Okay, entweder haben wir es jetzt,
oder wir kriegen es nicht mehr.
Auf, auf, auf, drop mich, drop mich.
Gachi-Bass.
What the fuck?
Okay, nice.
Haha, geil.
Das hat's gebracht.
Okay, jetzt wird's schwer.
Jetzt, jetzt wird's schwer.
By the way, ich benutze
das Ding einfach nur zum Vorfahren.
Ich stell das dann irgendwo ab,
wo ich gunnern kann.
Von da vorne.
Fahr jetzt einfach mitten in die Base rein.
So, der kann jetzt gunnern.
Oh, nice.
Gunnern mal eine Runde.
What the fuck, Alter?
Da standen grad 20 Gegner.
Please, break it, break it, break...
Nein.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht krieg ich ja noch.
Und wir haben nur noch 5 Tickets.
Oder wir sind dead.
2, 1, 0.
Fuck, die sind noch rankommen.
Okay, wir haben verloren.
Sag mal,
war der Typ zu blöd, E zu halten?
Hat er E nicht gehalten, der andere?
Ich glaub, der hat E losgelassen.
Der Diffuser.
Da war niemand mehr von uns.
Und wir hatten keine Tickets mehr.
Der hat einfach nicht E gedrückt.
Ja, das ist der Drohnencamper-Typ.
Wie ist das denn?
Career Best.
Wundert mich.
Auf was auch immer sich Career Best bezieht.
Bestimmt auf die Waffe, oder?
Anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Weil...
So, continue.
Also Leute,
bis 17 Uhr würde ich noch machen.
Dann reicht es mir für heute.
Vielleicht, mal gucken.
So, was haben wir denn hier freigeschaltet?
Carbon Series.
Next reward.
Close.
Collection, zeig doch mal her.
Haben wir da jetzt irgendwas?
Komischer Griff.
Aim down sight accuracy.
Naja, ist jetzt nicht so
als streut das Ding großartig.
Ich hätte halt gerne
das Magazin.
Ne, Moment.
Das hat auch noch 20 Schuss.
Ich brauch noch
35 Kills.
Für das ordentliche Magazin.
Leute, ne Runde Bots.
5 Minuten Bots
haben wir das freigeschaltet.
Oder 2 Minuten Bots haben wir das freigeschaltet.
Ich hoffe,
wir sind Attacker.
Orbital Defense mag ich nicht.
Brückentag morgen hast du mitgenommen.
Nö.
Wir sind Defense natürlich.
Defenders.
Defendige.
Morgen muss ich arbeiten.
Freitags ist eh nicht viel los.
Und im Brückentag ist erst recht nichts los.
Also insofern
ist es nicht weiter wild.
Morgen Homeoffice.
7 Uhr, 15.30, 16 Uhr.
Fertig.
Okay, der fährt doch dahin, wo ich hin wollte.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich will hier oben an den Felsen.
Wenn ich Glück habe,
bin ich vor den Gegnern da.
Äh.
Ja, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Gibt es eigentlich keine Proximity-Granaten
mehr für Assaults?
Perfekt.
Oh.
What the?
Not ganz sicher,
von wo ich beschossen werde.
Ähm.
Alles klar.
Ich check da nix.
Okay, nice.
Lohnt es sich
deiner Meinung nach das Game?
Ja, jetzt zu der Season, warum nicht?
Schadet schon nix.
Ich hab doch gesagt, dass ich Orbital Defense nicht mag.
Damit hat er nicht gerechnet,
dass da einer mit der Shotgun
im Busch steht.
Nice. Close, close, close.
Okay, mehr killen
kann ich grad nicht.
Not possible.
Sommer!
MonkaS, Alter.
Oh, da kommt was.
Tankge.
Oh, Tankge.
Passt, passt.
Die Shotgun, die Secondary-Shotgun
ist wirklich ganz nice.
Wenn du die rausholst und dann one-shottest,
da rechnen die halt so gar nicht mit.
Ja.
Okay, ich bleib jetzt einfach liegen
und bewege mich nicht.
Ihr seht mich nicht, ihr seht mich nicht.
Boah, meine Güte, was ist hier grad los?
Boah, was ist hier los?
Ich krieg gleich einen Herzinfarkt.
Oder einen Schlaganfall
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das mach ich Boomer-technisch
pack ich das nicht mehr.
Kann die Waffe mal aufhören zu sucken auf Range?
Na gut, es liegt auch am
Schalldämpfer ein bisschen.
Max, du wurdest geradet, aber nicht in Twitch?
Versteh ich nicht.
Oh shit, das ist...
Wo wurde ich geradet?
Wie kriegt ihr das nicht hin da unten?
Alter, ich fass es nicht.
Ach so,
weil ich von 20 Gegnern überrannt wurde.
Okay, ja, stimmt.
Wir haben es ernsthaft verloren noch, ne?
Okay, ich bin dead-ge.
Ich bin dead-ge.
Ich versuch mal abzuhauen.
Big ass tank, ja?
Ganschi-Tank.
Mal hinterherflitzen in der Hoffnung,
dass wir irgendwie noch hinkommen.
Ja, ja, lasst mich in Ruhe.
Das Spawnen ist schon...
Naja.
Was soll ich machen?
Es wäre besser gewesen, ich hätte mich einfach umgebracht
und wäre respawned.
Oh, dumme Spawn-Position.
Ja, die Sprüche in Battlefield 3
waren geil.
I get fucked up in the ass over here.
Und was hatten sie noch?
I get drilled in your asshole,
Battlefield 3.
Und die hatten ganz viele solche Sprüche.
Ganz ehrlich, die Battlefield 3 Sprüche haben mich so angehört,
als könnten es halt echt welche in einem Gefecht sagen.
Du sagst da halt, guck mal,
du sitzt hinter irgendeiner...
Du sitzt hinter irgendeiner Sandkiste,
oder hinter irgendeinem Sandsack.
Du sitzt in irgendeiner Stellung
und wirst beschossen.
Du sagst doch sicherlich nicht,
oh, die FeindInnen bewegen sich auf unsere Stellung hinzu.
Du sagst, alter, die ficken mich weg gerade.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich meine, ich bin froh,
dass ich noch nie in der Situation gewesen bin.
Ich glaube, du hast echt andere Probleme,
als da korrekt, korrekt zu reden.
Habe ich das neue Magazin...
Ach so, nee, das neue Magazin zackt ja auch.
Was kann man hier machen?
Ach nee, das ist die Tür.
Da vorne ist auf jeden Fall noch was.
Ich sehe aber nichts.
Ich sehe nichts.
Da ist er.
Ja super, natürlich ist irgendein Dude hinter mir jetzt noch.
Doch sicherlich ist das der neue Trend, ja.
Also wenn du verrecken willst, wahrscheinlich.
Ich finde übrigens gut,
dass die diese Bunnyhop-Geschichte dringelassen haben.
Das hat so ein bisschen...
Spiced so das Movement ein bisschen ab noch.
Wirklich vorwärts kommen sie ja auch nicht, ne?
Da ist einer.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, voll in den Kopf reiner.
Ah, shit.
Ich dachte, ich kann ihn outmoven,
indem ich auf den Hügel gehe und von oben runterhüpfe.
Aber, haha, nicht funktioniert.
Hätte aber auch funktionieren können.
Und jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Jetzt sind wir ganz schön weit weg.
Ich komme hier ein bisschen schneller hin,
wenn ich hier meinen...
Nice.
Okay, ich muss sagen,
SPP gart sich schon etwas weniger,
als am Anfang des Streams.
SPP gart Aim nicht mehr ganz so krass.
PP gart Aim zwar immer noch ziemlich,
aber nicht mal ganz so heftig wie am Anfang des Streams.
Ich glaube, hier werde ich gleich gesniped,
wenn ich weiterlaufe.
Okay, da kommen gerade ziemlich viele.
Vielleicht, habe ich Glück.
Probier es einfach mal.
Mein...
Nicht wirklich gehittet, oder?
Ey, ich fasse es nicht, der ist da wirklich dran.
Ja, ich wusste, dass du da durchgehst, Kollege.
So nicht.
Ey, pssst.
Das...
Das Visier macht mich ganz verrückt.
Hallo.
Lul.
Au, boah.
Ihr Säcke.
Best weapon in season 5.
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Keine Ahnung.
This one is nice,
but it's from the last season.
But it sucks,
with a...
20 round mag and
the standard
optics.
Die wurden schön geschotkert, oder?
Jetzt gibt es, es gibt...
Mittlerweile gibt es Rush, ja.
Bravo ist neutralized.
Ja, da müssen wir uns
jetzt einfach hier rein campen.
Oh, shit. Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Da müssen wir uns jetzt einfach hier rein campen, zu A.
Und wenn ich Glück habe, retzt mich
das Soldier hier.
Das wäre extremely pog.
Macht er aber nicht.
Der campt sich lieber in den...
Container.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch Container-Feel 2042.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie die auch so machen.
So, da oben ist...
Oh, shit, Alter. Wie viel ist denn da los?
Okay, 8 Tickets noch.
Wir müssen jetzt aufpassen.
Die werden... Oh, die pushen, pushen, pushen.
Dettke.
Startet gerade die Rakete?
Kann das sein?
Raketenstelz?
Nice.
Puh, anstrengend.
Wir haben, glaube ich, dreimal die neue Map
gespielt. Chat, was denkt ihr
von der neuen Map? Ich finde die
sehr...
Weiß nicht, so von der Optik her auf Rush
so sehr 0815, Schneelandschaft,
kaputte Gebäude und halt...
Ja, keine Züge, äh, keine Container,
sondern Züge. Oder Zugcontainer,
leere Zugwaggons.
Also,
macht durchaus einen ganz
okayen Eindruck, die neue
Map, ja. Zumindest, zumindest
in Rush. Haben wir was Scheiß
unlockt für die Waffe?
Ansonsten, tja, was...
Das war's ja eigentlich. Es gibt, glaube ich, keinen
neuen Specialist die Season.
High Power Rounds.
Okay.
Zeigt mal her.
Looks like the wait's over.
Was haben wir denn hier?
High Power Rounds.
Recoil Control, Reload Speed,
Rate of Fire.
Naja, kann man mal
equipped lassen, falls man
keine Muni mehr hat, aber nee, nee, nee.
Eher nicht.
Und die ist eigentlich genau genug. Also, ich glaube,
das ist durchaus okay so.
Es wird immer noch gestellt. Ja, ich denke noch so
eine halbe Stunde oder so. Denke ich mal so ungefähr.
Chat, wie gesagt,
morgen, ich vermute wahrscheinlich eher am Samstag,
machen wir wieder ein bisschen Progress streamen.
Wir haben schon lange kein Kekiava-Skript
mehr gemacht. Ich hab Hunger.
Dabei ist es noch...
Normalerweise esse ich so irgendwie
so 18 Uhr rum. Dabei ist
noch eineinhalb Stunden hin. Aber
PPoFatTime kommt eigentlich nie früh genug.
PPoFatTime.
BPM.
Okay, wieder Attacker. Ich glaube,
Attacker haben wir die heute noch gar nicht gespielt.
Doch, haben wir. Doch, doch.
Oder?
Ja, ja, doch. Wir haben die sogar gewonnen.
Die Runde hat richtig gesuckt, die letzte Attacker-Runde.
Aber mein Team hat's gerissen.
Doch, doch. Wir haben die schon...
Ich glaube, Attacker-Runde gespielt.
Set Servers? Wirklich? Schon wieder neue?
Das wollte ich mal
kurz checken. Die machen wir dann.
Also nicht...
Show me Set Servers released.
Ne.
Die haben wir schon gemacht.
Oh. Ich hab den Anfang verpasst.
So, wenn wir
Glück haben,
kann ich rechts irgendwie durch und aufs...
Oh, oh, oh.
Ja, nice.
By the way, deswegen haben die sich
das Team von Need for Speed geholt bei der Entwicklung.
Dass sie geile Fahrzeugphysik
haben. Sollte mal
erwähnt werden, finde ich.
Wo sind sie denn?
Wo sind... What the...
Da war er.
Okay.
Oh, shit. Da ist grad einer gespawnt.
Da mit dem hab ich nicht gerechnet.
Ne, die
Neuen hab ich gemacht.
Ich hab schon Set-Server alle.
Die sind schon nicht mehr Set-ge.
Okay.
Nice.
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, Mann.
Warum sehen die mich hier immer?
Ich bin doch so komplett gestelzt
mit meinem Silencer.
Anscheinend nicht gestelzt genug.
Hä?
Okay, das waren Boomer-Augen,
aber ich hab den nicht kommen sehen.
Der war auf einmal da.
Waren das Boomer-Augen oder habt ihr den auch nicht gesehen?
Chatge.
Yeah, seriously.
Das hat den nicht gekillt, gerade.
Da hat nur der Kopf rausgeguckt.
Ich hab extra auf die Pistole geswitcht.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Ach, der lebt gar nicht mehr.
Oh, da hinten schneidert was.
Wenn wir schnell sind...
Ach, guck mal, wir haben sogar schon die Legehände gemacht.
Nice.
Easy.
Oh, hier, wir sind schon durch.
Zack.
Ah.
Boom.
Big Shuck.
Ah, nee, hier geht's ja nicht weiter.
So, jetzt müssen wir
unter die Brücke.
Oh, shit, hier geht's ja gar nicht weiter.
Das war sehr pepega von mir.
Jetzt können sie nämlich voll in die Seite ballern.
Bleibt mal hinterm Busch.
Busch, Busch-Stelz.
So, darf ich...
Dürfen wir please foregame?
Ist das erlaubt?
Nice. So, jetzt müssen wir unter die Brücke.
Wir rennen einfach.
Einfach Lebensmittel...
Da ist doch ein Gegner, oder?
Shit, der wusste es.
Ich hab die Kiste auf der Map gesehen
und dachte mir so...
Wir sacken gerade richtig rein.
Ey, ich schieb sie einfach mal
auf die Map, easy.
Let's get going.
Moment, ich bin an der
Legehenne dran.
Ich hör hier Gegner rumstelzen.
Da war schon der Erste, ey.
Und da ist der Nächste. Hier.
Woah, weggesniped.
Krieg ich ein Reds?
Ich hab released in dem Moment, wo ich
gefragt hab, krieg ich ein Reds?
Okay.
Was ist da hinten los?
Was ist denn
Charlie Mike? Oscar Mike
kenne ich noch aus Call of Duty und sowas.
Oscar Mike is on the move.
Und was ist Charlie Mike?
C-Move?
Jett-Cock-Move?
Falls das irgendjemand
von euch High IQ Checkern weiß.
Okay, YOLO.
Okay, pass auf.
Ich hör die über mir.
Ich leg mich jetzt hin.
Ich mach den krassen Stealth-Move.
Ihr wisst nicht,
dass ich da bin.
Ihr habt gar keine Ahnung, dass ich da bin.
So, und sobald er defused...
Lul.
Über mir ist einer.
Der hüpft gleich runter.
Nee, der ist auf dem Dach.
Ach, der ist gar nicht da.
Lul.
Ich glaub, es wird easy win.
Continue
Mission.
Jett, ihr habt nachgeguckt, oder?
Ich geb's zu, ihr habt nachgeguckt.
Ihr habt nachgeguckt.
Continue Mission.
Continue Moving? Ja, kann auch sein.
Haben wir nicht gerade schon
easy win? Och, ernsthaft?
Kacknoobs.
Ich muss mal kurz meine Pistole
reloaden.
Hätte ich den dritten erwischt, wär halt schon
nice gewesen, ne?
Es waren aber zu viele. Es sind irgendwie
gerade... Puh.
Über mir, über mir, über mir.
Muss mal kurz reloaden.
Alter, die desarmen die ganze
Zeit. Was ist das hier?
Die sollen mal aufhören
gescheit zu spielen.
Au.
Hört mal auf, euch Mühe zu geben, Gegners.
Okay, da müssen wir von oben reinballern.
Anders geht das nicht.
Jawoll, jetzt haben sie keine Chance.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, sie ficken uns
von der Seite.
Sie haben... Hey!
Ist das die Hexe?
Ist das Hexe, die da gerade spielt?
Der Name sieht so ähnlich
aus. Zeig mal.
Nee, nee, nee, ist es nicht.
Sah nur ähnlich aus. Hätte mich auch gewundert.
Ich dachte, der spielt kein Battlefield mehr, aber...
Name sah nur so ähnlich aus.
Das war eigentlich
eine recht gute Runde zum Schluss hin noch.
Top Rex, so wie das
sein muss. Guck mal, 38
Jahre, 38 Kills.
Das heißt, umso älter...
Ich glaube, ihr
habt es alle gesehen.
Es macht
keinen Sinn zu behaupten, ich habe 38 Kills.
Es waren bloß 23.
Das heißt aber auch, umso älter ich werde, umso mehr Kills
muss ich machen.
Wer ist Hexe? Ein ziemlich guter Battlefield
Spieler, BF3, BF4,
von dem ich schon einige Gameplays benutzt habe.
Hexe, Battlefield...
Ja.
Der hier.
Der geht halt richtig ab.
Irgendwie hat mich der Name nur gerade ein bisschen
dran erinnert.
Der hat auch irgendeinen
Account mit P.
Und irgendwie dachte ich, vielleicht ist er das,
aber ist er nicht.
Ach, kommt Tactical Muscle Break.
Ach!
Nice! Endlich!
Collection.
Jawohl.
Endlich 30 Schuss drin.
Was ist das?
Was sind die Nachteile gewesen?
Mal kurz checken.
Was waren die Nachteile?
Reload Speed.
Discarded. Okay, Schrott-Map.
Aber, ja hast recht,
Schrott-Map, aber zum ersten Mal
heute, insofern ganz okay.
Wie switcht man den
Crample nochmal?
So.
Das Menü ist immer noch ziemlich
Crap, ne?
30 Kills noch
für das ordentliche Visier.
Und wieder
Attacker. So mag ich das.
Ich hoffe,
wurde die schon überarbeitet oder kommt die noch?
Ich glaub, das kommt noch.
Die haben nur ein bisschen M-Comps und so umplatziert.
Weil,
wenn sie schon überarbeitet wurde,
dann finde ich die Map
zu Überarbeitung müllig.
Okay, die haben
sie überarbeitet.
Die Objectives sind jetzt woanders als das letzte Mal.
Hier waren sonst die Objectives immer drinnen.
Okay.
Damit hab ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Okay, neue Map.
Ah shit, PP geaimt.
Oh oh.
Wusste, dass ich dead
hier bin.
Aber vielleicht kann ich hier wieder reinspawnen, schnell.
Ja, nice.
Mein Team geht ab.
Nicht eine gute Aktion
bisher in der Runde und nicht eine richtige Aktion
in der Runde hier, aber trotzdem easy win.
Geh mal da oben drauf.
Da haben wir ein bisschen was zu gucken.
Ach, hier sind wir jetzt.
Das hat sonst nie jemand benutzt
auf der Map, diesen Part in Rush.
Wie hab ich denn den Kill
gekriegt, Lul?
Ich muss jetzt da oben drauf, um den zu killen.
Lass mich da oben drauf.
Es.
Geschudet.
Okay, die Map, finde ich, spielt sich
jetzt nach diesem
nach diesem neuen
Placement von den M-Comps tatsächlich
ein bisschen angenehmer an, zumindest der Anfang.
Kann aber auch täuschen,
weil wir die so überrannt haben.
Bis auf Hourglass.
Echt, haben sie es jetzt geschafft, ja?
Oh.
Chatkey, ist die nur Headshot, One-Shot oder ist
die immer One-Shot?
Weil immer
One-Shot ist suck.
Headshot, One-Shot, Sniper, Bolt-Action
ist komplett
in Ordnung.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist eine C4-Drohne, oder?
Ist das eine C4-Drohne?
Die sah so
fett C4-t aus.
Oh shit.
Okay, wenn ich Glück habe.
Ich bin einfach hier stehen geblieben.
Fuck.
Sniper machen nur One-Shot.
Nee.
Es gab eine Sniper, die hat One-Shot, Body-Shot
gemacht, oder One-Shot, Upper-Body, Body-Shot
auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß aber nicht mal, welche das war.
Diese N-T-irgendetwas.
One-Shot, Headshot, Sniper sind gut.
One-Shot, Body-Shot, Sniper nicht.
Kann man sowas hier machen?
Oh oh.
Der hat ein Hemd auf mich.
Ach nee, man darf hier gar nicht drauf.
Sehr gut. Ich darf mich nicht bewegen, sonst bin ich dead.
Tolle Pose hier.
Das ist doch auch ein Bug, oder?
Dass das hier
noch offen ist.
Jetzt dürfen wir.
Okay, hier ist schon die Legehenne ab.
Die Legehenne am Start.
Sollen wir hier rauf gucken?
Okay, Legehenne.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir nur mal schauen,
dass hier keiner reinkommt. Ich weiß nicht, von wo kommen die hier eigentlich?
Von da? Von da?
Ich kenne den Fluss da.
Von oben?
Von da? Okay, der geht aber, glaube ich,
gerade ran.
Okay, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung gehabt, von wo der reingekommen ist.
Aber ist egal,
wir haben ihn gekillt. Und jetzt?
Bam!
Legehenne, successful.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, nein.
Ihr seht,
absolute exzellente Map-Kenntnis.
Peak, peak.
Performance Battlefield.
Was kommt jetzt als nächstes?
Kommt jetzt das große Schiff?
Das andere Schiff noch?
Sind die gleich geblieben?
Und diese Dinger verwirren mich hier in der Luft.
Nice.
Einfach mal, einfach mal.
Einfach mal random hingeballert.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben.
Jo.
Nice.
Damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet,
dass euch der alte Sack
wegstellst hier.
Die haben jetzt richtigen Keckweight gemacht, gerade.
Ah, von der anderen
Seite.
Huch, wo kommt der her?
Äh, alles klar.
Wir sind, wir sind komplett
gewiped.
Oben, da oben ist was.
Das halte ich, das halte ich für ein Gerücht, dass da oben was ist.
Ja.
Oh shit, da ist wirklich was.
Nice, nicer call, nicer call.
Ich hätte nicht mit
gerechnet, dass da oben wirklich was drauf liegt.
Habt ihr schon einmal einen guten Ping
bekommen in dem Spiel, wo jemand wirklich
was Sinnvolles gepingt hat? Ich nicht bis jetzt.
Das ist Premiere.
Ich habe so selten gute Pings bekommen,
dass ich noch nie mal damit gerechnet habe, dass das stimmt.
Okay, okay, ich
hau ab. So, wie machen wir
das jetzt am besten? Okay, mein Squad
Sack, ich muss Squads wechseln. Wie wechselt man
Squads? Squads, alles, wie?
Alles voll. Nee, das ist aber doof.
Ich will,
ich will zu denen, dass ich da, dass ich da spawnen
kann. Ey, alles
voll, das ist natürlich doof.
Na, dann gehen wir bei ihm hier.
Alter, was ist denn hier los? Die sterben ja
links und rechts gerade, wir haben kaum noch Tickets.
Jetzt müssen wir echt, müssen wir echt aufpassen.
Ah, es stellt immer einer hinter einem.
Es ist immer der Typ,
immer der Typ, den man nicht sieht. So ist es halt
im Battlefield. Okay, wenn
wir schnell sind.
Okay, hier ist nix.
Lege Henne.
Okay, ich warte jetzt
einfach hier und wenn die kommen
zum Diffusen, springe ich runter und bash
die. Das ist der Plan.
Ich bleibe jetzt, ich camp
das M-Com jetzt einfach ab.
Jawoll, gleich haben wir es.
Gleich haben wir es. Alpha ist auch gleich
dead.
Jawoll, nice. Ah, jetzt
kommt ja noch einer.
Ist gleich viel nicer, ohne Scheiß, mit mehr Schuss
drinne. Oh, jetzt wird es hier richtig
international hier im Stream.
Chat, nach der Runde ist Schluss.
Wenn ihr noch irgendwelche
Fragen habt oder Vorschläge für nächste
Streams, irgendwas in der Richtung, dann
schießt los. Ich gucke danach nochmal
eine Viertelstunde oder so im Chat.
Oh, ich bin tot. Ich bin so dead.
Lass mal was probieren.
Bunnyhopping.
Dass es ein bisschen schneller geht.
Okay, okay, okay. Und jetzt hier.
Jetzt hier rauf.
Hoffentlich ist da oben nicht so viel los.
Shit, ich dachte, das ist der Gegner.
Ah, auf der
rechten Seite. Fuck.
Ja, da machst du nix, wenn da einer mit so ner
krassen Sentry rumhockt. Ich hätte
unten warten sollen, dass die Leute reinspawnen können.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Please, please, please.
Oh, Spawnbeacon. Exzellent. Fiveheader.
Richtiger
Macher hier.
Okay, wir sind...
What the fuck?
Diablo 4 Crying. Ich hab's mir tatsächlich noch
nicht gekauft.
Okay, A ist...
Okay, ich hoffe, die sind jetzt alle dead.
Okay, brauchen wir noch?
B, B. Wo ist denn B überhaupt?
Wo ist denn B?
Unter mir?
Warte mal, wo ist B? Da, da. Okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich...
Ich kenn die Map nicht. Ich bin zu...
Ist B hier?
Hier ist B, oder?
Alter, bin ich pp-geil.
Ich hab ja so keinen Plan von dem Game.
Aber wir haben's. Nice.
Oh.
Oh, gut.
Pogu.
Oh.
Aus jetzt für heute, ey.
Vier Stunden Battlefield.
Für mich mit 38 ist das schon
quasi Arbeitstag vorbei.
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr so lange konzentrierten.
Chat, ich geh gleich was futtern.
Wir sehen uns spätestens
Samstag.
Samstag machen wir ein bisschen Javascript.
Progress-Streamstellens.
Sonntag eh zum Aufwachen.
Vielleicht noch morgen, aber dann Samstag.
Mal gucken. Gucken wir mal.
Ich denke mal sogar morgen schon.
Brückentag mäßig bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht so kaputt.
Da ist nicht so viel los.
EA App sign out.
Alles klar.
Nee, Diablo hab ich nicht gekauft.
Also alles klar, wir sehen uns heute.
Bis dahin, macht's gut. See you.